e
all right uh the time being
10:06 good morning uh we will get
started I don't have my gavel today so
this
is no I have I have one I just uh was
rushing out this morning um so first up
LBA take it away good morning cret from
the legislative budget assistance office
um I'm here today just to kind of give
you an overview of what the committee's
charge is as it relates to um estimating
the unrestricted funds for the general
fund fishing game fund and Highway fund
and the general fund would include the
education trust fund so before you I
handed out a packet looks like this I'm
not going to speak to the entire thing
I'm only going to try to be up here for
as little time as possible so that I can
bring Lindsay and her team up so they
can talk you about the more fun and
exciting things um so as you understand
um you're here to do some Revenue
estimates um you're only doing the
unrestricted Revenue estimate it's not
for the entire budget it's only those
things that haven't been assigned for a
particular function within the budget um
so like for fishing game you're you're
only doing about $13 million of Revenue
estimates when they spend much more than
that because they have several dedicated
revenue streams which the finance
committee will work with and make sure
that the budget is balanced our staff if
you turn to just inside the front page
is a listing of our staff from our
office our offices consist of seven
individuals there's the LBA U myself the
deputy LBA
and then we have four budget analysts
and our support person and what we do
for you is all the fiscal notes on the
bills so we review all the lsrs that
come out so so far this year we've
looked at over 12200 lsrs or redrafts to
see if they need a fiscal note and then
we if they do we try to put something on
there um right now we've got around 400
bills that we've assigned a fiscal note
too in addition to that um our staff is
also responsible for doing fiscal impact
statements on the rules
and we do just over 300 of those a
year our primary charge though is to
assist the the legislative body with the
development of the operating budget the
capital budget um and that's what we
will mainly do this session so um I'm
here for you the rest of the staff is at
the finance committee um helping them
get through that process so I'm going to
walk you through what you're going to do
here and how it ties back into the
budget process again stay at a high
level um and just kind of ask questions
as they pop up for you so you've started
to hear from um the economic briefings
last week you're going to hear from
agencies this week in the next couple of
weeks where they'll come in with their
estimates on the revenues that they
generate or collect for the state um
that go into the unrestricted pots um as
we do that I start to put together if
you turn to page four of the document um
we've called it it's a worksheet and we
try to put in there all the information
that the agencies provide you as it
relates to their revenue estimates so
you can see it in one
place if you flip to the page five
you'll see that what we do with the Dr
estimates because they typically are the
only agency that provides you a range we
try to provide a separate table with the
range of their estimates and then
looking on page six you'll see the
spreadsheet that we fill out as it
relates to the general and education
trust fund we give you what the two
years ago so fiscal you'll see fiscal 22
when this was done for the last
operating budget we had fiscal 22 what
the official plan was for revenues 25
what the official plan or 20 excuse me
23 what the official plan was any
adjustments that the governor might have
made and then the agency's estimates
followed by what the house Ways and
Means estimates might be so you go
through that process you you'll end up
doing doing some work sessions to um
determine what you agree to as the
numbers for the committee you do the
same thing for the highway fund and for
the fishing game fund and I noticed that
represent Brier isn't here today but um
as many of you have probably heard he
worked for Department of Safety before
retiring and he did was the director of
road tolls which is the entity that
collects all the highway funds so you've
got an expert on your committee to to
talk about that when it comes
time once the committee has done all its
work and come to an agreement on what
they believe the revenue estimates
should be if you turn to page
14 typically there's a resolution put
together for the house and we take the
current fiscal year with the official
estimate was any revisions so the one
you're looking at is hr17 for the 2023
session you'll see that the official
estimate was the first column then the
committee estimate so that would be any
adjustments you might make because you
have better information on what the
revenue stream is is like at that moment
and then what your estimates for 24 and
25 are typically this goes to the house
tabled from there I take these numbers
we do an amendment to House Bill one so
if you turn to
page
21 house bill one is the operating
budget
typically so we prepare an amendment
usually in the chair of of finance's
name and we take the house Ways and
Means official estimates and we put them
into this this amendment to the house
bill uh to House Bill one or the
operating budget those become the
numbers that the house finance committee
is using to make sure they come up with
a balance budget for the
unrestricted um entities so we do again
you do it for your general funds Highway
funds and then your fishing game fund
we'll go through the same process when
we move on to the Senate our office
works for both the Senate and the house
we
nonpartisan um so we'll go through this
same process with the Senate um we'll
come back and report to you what changes
the Senate might have made um your
committee will decide if you agree
disagree um and in most years there's a
committee a conference where you um the
legislative bodies will come together
and and hash out their final agreement
which you usually involves a several
members of ways and means that we'll
look at the final numbers and come to
some conclusion on what they believe
be as you move as the process moves
along now um you turn to page
23 your committee is going to be seeing
bills you're going to have bills that
are may impact Revenue when you're doing
your estimates you're doing your
estimates on what current law is today
not what bills you might pass from this
body from this committee or the house
body what we do on our office on the
Surplus statement which you can see
starts on
23 we'll make adjustments for changes
that the bodies agree to so if the house
passes a bill that changes the interest
rate um for or the tax rate for the one
of the business taxes we'll put a line
on the Surplus statement accounting for
that change so you it will then be
netted against any estimates you have
have
provided that may change when it gets to
the Senate that's why we ask the revenue
estimates be done based on current
law and if you turn to page
um
26 just to show
you rows two through S it's called
schedule two and it's rows two through 7
on page
26 those would be all revenue
adjustments that were made
the last operating budget and you'll see
what the governor proposed what the
house proposed what the Senate proposed
if there had been a committee of
conference there would be a last fourth
column that would be the committee of
Conference Final
proposal um but you can see that for
instance the one of the big changes last
time was how much how you did the split
for the um general fund education trust
fund for the business taxes it used to
be a fairly
complicated calculation now it's just a
great percentage and you can see the
house had one percentage the governor
had a different percentage and the
senate had a third percentage and we
make those adjustments within the um
final operating budget so that we know
that um you have a bounced budget that
you will pass at least based on what the
best estimates of that
day so when uh would a committee of
conference come in because all these
estimates are different so what how do
these get so in 2023 the um the house
accepted the changes from the Senate and
the bill went forward so there was no
Committee of conference okay if there
had been um a decision for a committee
of conference that would have occurred
in the June time frame um and we would
have had a fourth column here where you
would have seen any agreements or things
that you agreed to keep doing or things
you didn't want to do would come out and
they it have a new number for the Cs
Committee of conference um final vote
okay thank you representative Aly
yes just to be clear a June time frame
means that at least some of us all of us
have to be here at the very end of June
to vote on the final
decision and typically for the house
bill one house bill two Committee of
conference there's a couple of house
Ways and Means Comm members that are
assigned to that um it it varies from
time to time but um my experience has
been uh that that the ways and means
members from both the house and the
Senate will typically take a moment and
discuss the estimates and may come back
to the committee of conference with
suggestions on what they can agree to or
not agree to between the two
bodies um no guarantee that's going to
happen this time because that's up to
leaderships of both sides to determine
um how they want to go forward with a
committee of conference okay any other
question but I just more importantly
that the piece that I want you to take
away from that is as you work on
bills if you pass pass those from the
house to the Senate we will take care of
that on the Surplus statement we'll
account for that additional revenue or
the reduction of Revenue depending on
what the Bill's doing so so when you're
doing your Revenue estimates in the next
couple of weeks it's getting just on
current law not in the bills you may be
working on at that same
time any other questions are we good
everything's Crystal Clear good all
right continue if you p uh skip to page
36 so you wonder what happens to all
this information you know once it's gone
through the legislative body and been
signed into law by the governor it then
goes over to the Department of
administrative services and they put
together the revenue
plan and the revenue plan basically
takes the total number of revenue for
the year and tries to allocate it by
month it's an estimated allocation it's
based on typically on percentages of
Prior years or maybe a a new known issue
that the agency knows that we got to
collect money um in this month more so
than we did in other months due to some
change in law so the the monthly Revenue
plan just gives you a sense of how we're
doing how we trending so this is the
official estimate this is what is bound
by law it doesn't
change um so even if in the second year
of the session you pass bills that have
an impact on Revenue it won't change the
official plan they'll make a note of it
um as they collect the revenue and the
revenue Focus potentially and that would
be the next thing you would look at um
on page 40 and I think that your very
first meeting um I think representative
janigan mentioned the revenue
Focus so that is the document that the
department of administrative Services
issues at the end of every month that
tells you how you did on a month on a
monthly basis so what you were
anticipated to collect for each of the
revenue sources the unrestricted revenue
for um the general fund and the
education trust fund as well as the
highway fund and um fishing game fund
but but the front page typically focuses
on the general fund education trust fund
it's for the current month on the right
hand side there's a column that will
have little narratives those are the
agencies will work with administrative
services to comment on what might have
happened in that month why did we get so
much more Revenue than usual or why was
it less or why does it go in this bucket
and not that bucket
you'll then you'll see that that that's
the um year-to date so it's the same
idea but it's what you've collected
year-to date you can see you know
through in this instance it's through
December 2025 you can see how much
you've collected for the general fund
how much you've collected for the
education trust fund and how that
compares to what your plans were for
each of those and if you were to go down
to the total receipts line You'll see
that the general fund which is the first
uh column is $12.6 million ahead of plan
through December you go to the middle
column which is the education trust fund
you'll see that the education trust fund
is $ 53.8 million below plan and then
when you get to the total the two of
those net out and you'll see that
you're 41 um2 million below plan
overall thank you Mike uh Kane came and
spoke to you from our office the other
day and he suggested that point in time
if we were to close the year out we
would be about $25 million in the
whole uh of General funds so based on
Appropriations and other activities that
have occurred um you know your revenues
are are not as strong as they were
originally anticipated to
be but there may be different reasons
and then on the LA you turn the page the
43 the last page of the revenue Focus
you have the highway fund and the
fishing game fund again those those are
two other unrestricted Revenue sources
that this committee will be weighing in
on and providing an estimate based on um
you the remainder of the document is um
basically the rsas that um allow for the
taxes to be collected it shows you the
rates and such but I'm not going to go
through through
that I just wanted to give you kind of a
couple minutes of why I'm here to help
guide you through this process and make
sure that your decisions are put into
the places they need to be so they end
up in a house resolution and they end up
in the house bill one Amendment for your
unrestricted Revenue I'm also here to
help bring the agencies in so that you
can hear them present on the different
Revenue
sources I'm here also
to uh track down information that you
might find you need for the committee I
may not have it myself but I may need to
find a resource that can get it to you
um so that's all I had for you um I'll
be here as you work on your unrestricted
revenues and then once that's done you
won't see much of me because I'll be
working with the Senate and doing other
things but then I'll be coming back um
as we get closer to the end of the
Senate process to um let you know what's
been happening unless I'm invited back
um for a specific
reason so I don't know if anybody has
any questions or I guess uh I have a
general question um so if we look at
page
42 the um so far the total total
receipts are 12.6 million ahead of plan
for general for the general
fund and the education uh trust fund is
53 million below planned um is in a
nutshell could you tell us
why why that is so much lower in general
what what is that pulling from or why is
there a way to summarize that um so you
can see that most of the the issue is
with your business
taxes you know you get a $54 million and
then your tobacco tax which has been
million okay they're generally both
coming in less than what was planned for
um there may be some other issues with
the business taxes I can't relate to or
I discuss with you that that would
probably be more appropriate for
Lindsay's team to mention to you because
I just don't know right um but there may
be some issues with when we did the
estimates originally we estimated that
um the splits between the business bet
and BPT um were different than what
we're seeing today that may be having an
impact on some of this as well um Dr as
many of you who have been around know
they have a computer system they call
rims that um they put in a few years
years back and that's allowed them to
have a better sense of uh their revenue
Collections and where the how they are
coming in and particularly with their
business taxes where they belong so if a
taxpayer is filing their business
estimates and they put everything in bet
Dr can see that well typically X
percentage is your bet X percentage is
your BPT so they just move that
automatically for you that may be part
of what's happening in the business tax
row um but overall your business taxes
are not coming in as
planned okay representative ORS uh thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question so uh I was a little curious
about two things the tobacco tax why
might that be down so
much well I think when we made the
revenue estimates back in 2023 it was
based on numbers that you were seeing
coming out of covid and so when people
were home tobacco was up oh okay um the
sense is that when people are in their
home environment they not as reluctant
to have a cigarette or take a break for
a cigarette or smoke while they're
working whereas when you're in the
workplace you can't do that as people
have moved back into um the offices
there's been less of that so that's part
of it so our base may have been off to
um there's also the
um for the for the tobacco you have the
electric electronic cigarettes those
when when they're tax it all goes into
the general fund cigarettes are split
between the general fund and the
education trust fund so that may be why
you're seeing less going into the
education trust fund as well but again
I'll defer to Dr because they're much
more knowledgeable about these issues
than I okay and the second part of that
question would be the uh out ofate
sales I read somewhere we we we make
millions of dollars
on people coming across the border like
they do to buy liquor do you know what
that number is I don't I know that when
um there's estimates made around
changing a a tobacco tax rate there's
conversation about how how much you're
pulling across the border and if you go
too high you're going to lose those
crossb sales but I don't have a
percentage as to what that
is so when Dr comes up they'll be able
to be more specific with those sorts of
questions Chris is giving us the overall
process
but fair questions fair questions and
now Dr is going to be ready to answer
questions okay seeing none thank you
up all right good morning Mr chair
members of the committee Lindsay stpp
again I'm the commissioner at the
Department of Revenue and I'm here to
again walk through the various taxes
that Dr collects some of this
information will be repetitive from what
I gave last week but if you're anything
like me it sometimes doesn't stick till
the second or third time that you hear
it so um and then there's also some
additional information in here to really
kind of get you set and ready to do your
Revenue estimating uh process that Chris
just described well this is also a more
a deeper dive correct we are also going
to do a deeper dive to the taxes as well
thank you I think we're scheduled for
two hours
so we'll get to uh spend some quality
morning um okay so first um on page two
just a little bit more information about
the Department of Revenue so I've
included here our mission
statement which is to fairly and
efficiently administer the tax laws of
the State of New Hampshire collecting
the proper amount of taxes due while in
current ing the least cost to taxpayers
in a manner that merits the highest
degree of public confidence in our
integrity further we provide prompt and
constructive assistance to the municipal
units of government in the matters of
Budget Finance and the appraisal of real
estate so as I talked a little bit about
last week we we are the primary um
revenue and tax collection agency but we
also support the municipalities um for
the collection of local property taxes
as
well on page three just in terms of
interaction with our taxpayers the
policy of the Department of Revenue to
administer the tax laws in a manner that
demonstrates efficiency fairness and
courtesy towards every taxpayer um one
of the ways that we kind of monitor this
is when taxpayers call into our call
center they have an opportunity at the
end of the call to rate the knowledge
and professionalism of the person that
they spoke to on the phone and they're
also able to leave us a comment if they
have anything else to say and we
routinely score a five out of five on
the professionalism and knowledge of
oury employees um and we get some funny
comments from time to time that things
like oh this is so much better than
calling the IRS or
Massachusetts um I'm just happy you guys
answer the phone no one answers the
phone anymore these days so we do try
our very best to make sure that our
taxpayers um are satisfied it's not
everyone's favorite task to pay taxes
but we try to make it as painless as
possible on page four this is just um
our organizational chart just to give
you a little bit more perspective on the
department so there's the commissioner
and assistant commissioner and then
you'll see our primary divisions the
administration unit the audit division
the collections division Municipal and
property Division and taxpayer services
and then below each division you'll see
kind of some of the primary functions um
so the way that this is structured
really is if you're not under audit and
we're not trying to collect money from
you that's overdue most of your
interactions are going to be with our
tax payer services division so they man
our call center they process our Revenue
they process our
documents um that has allowed for a fair
bit of efficiency within the department
and so all of your routine interactions
are kind of going to be in that one
division the municipal and property unit
is the folks that interact most closely
with our um Municipal officials and our
local governments and then the
administration unit is kind of all the
back office functions of the
department within the administration
unit on page five we have tax policy and
legislative analysis group and that
those are folks that are sitting behind
me today we have Jennifer Ramsay who's
our tax policy Council Lauren O Sullivan
is our senior financial analyst and Gita
rala is our financial analyst those are
the folks you're going to see for the
most part um in terms of testifying on
behalf of bills explaining fiscal notes
and that sort of thing so you'll get to
know them quite well they do prepare our
fiscal note worksheets and also some
fiscal note quick guides which is kind
of a I don't know a more simpler version
of a fiscal note kind of easier to
understand that will provide to the
committee to assist you with the bills
where there's a fiscal impact they also
work with you as legislators in
analyzing tax policy and the associated
fiscal impact you will see them in
committee hearings they will testify
regarding um tax impact they track all
of the legislation and then they um
assist the department in Rule and form
changes that are the result of new laws
that are finally passed at the end of
the
year on page
six um the taxes at the Dr administer is
approximately $2.9 billion in Revenue so
here you have the taxes on the left you
have the current tax rate in the middle
column and then you have the relevant
statutes on the right so this can kind
of be a nice frame of reference if you
ever have any questions about the
current rates or how the tax
um are structured in the law you can
reference this slide um as Chris
mentioned there are a few taxes that we
do not collect we do not collect the
insurance premium tax uh we do not
collect although I think a fair number
of us pay into the beer tax um and we do
tax on page seven looking at a breakdown
of the taxes for fiscal year 2024
Revenue you will see business business
taxes collected uh just over 1.2
billion uh meals and rooms tax 328
million utility property tax 46.8
million just to give you a summary
billion we have a question represent Aly
thank
you um preliminary we don't have
anything from the cfer yet right the AER
has not been issued yet I believe Mike
Kane spoke about that last week um the
expectation is it'll be out either at
the end of this month or maybe um during
February so these are preliminary
numbers we would typically include the
AC for numbers here um but these are
based off the preliminary PR preliminary
acral that's issued by the department of
administrative
services do you know why it's taken so
long um I believe Mike explained that
part of the delay is the um transition
to a new system at The Liquor Commission
and um making sure that that is all
working and um reporting
properly so everything else would be
okay sort of as we can get right so um I
don't expect there to be significant
variation between these preliminary
numbers and the actual AER um when it's
issued with respect to any of the taxes
that Dr collects there's usually only
minor
adjustments um on page eight this is
just a kind of a pie of what um the
general and education trust fund Revenue
looks
like so dr's responsibilities are are in
bold face um and you'll see that that
equals about
here I would note um as was mentioned by
the treasurer during your present ations
last week that other which is currently
6% that includes interest that's been
earned on um monies that are sitting in
state accounts and that's higher than
it's been in other years due to the
amount of um Federal stimulus money that
spent okay moving to page nine the goal
here is to go through um each of the
taxes give an overview of the tax give a
trend history of the tax and then as um
the chair mentioned kind of dive a
little bit deeper into some additional
information unlike last time we're going
to lead with business taxes um and then
it'll get easier from here so first up
is the business profits
tax on the left hand side here you'll
see just a general overview of the tax
so the current rate is
75% every Enterprise organized for gain
or profit carrying carrying on any
business activity in the state is
subject to the tax and then in the third
bullet you'll see gross business income
in excess of $109,000 from all
activities that's the filing threshold
so any business that has gross business
income of
$109,000 or more is required to file and
that threshold is updated based on CPI
every two
years on the right hand side of the page
you'll see when people file and pay and
this is based on calendar year fil which
is roughly 90% of our
taxpayers so partnership returns are
going to be due on March 15th corporate
proprietorship and fiduciary returns are
due April
15th businesses do have a seven-month
extension to file but not to pay so long
as their account is fully paid by either
that March 15th or April 15th deadline
they have an automatic 7-month extension
and then they make estimated payments
equal to 25% of their liability on April
15th June 15th September 15th and
December
15th going to slide
10 this is a little bit
complicated so fair warning
but what we're trying to show here is
how a taxpayer with a calendar
year how their
payments will flow into the state's
fiscal year because calendar year and
fiscal year are
offset so at the top of the page you'll
see a calendar year tax filer that goes
from January 2024 to December
2024 you'll see those four quarterly
estimated payments in April June
September and December those are in
green you'll see their return
s in blue either in March April or May
depending on their entity type but then
if they file that return on extension if
they get that automatic seven-month
extension to fill out the return you'll
see those com in in the fall in October
November
December so those returns in blue and in
red are actually the returns from the
prior calendar
year so you'll see that really when we
get
returns they're almost a full year late
I shouldn't say late because they're not
late they're on time but a full year
since the end of the taxable period so
it can be a while before we at Dr get
that nice return with all of the
information on it that tells us what's
going on with that business prior to
that point the only information we have
is the estimated payments that that
they've made and those estimate forms
some of you have heard me joke about
this before those estimate forms are
very simple it's a name a taxpayer ID
number a period end date and a dollar
amount there's no little love note that
tells me why they're paying more or less
than they did previously it's just money
in the door so it's not until that final
return is filed that I really can dig
into what is going on with that business
why did they pay more or
less we have a question question uh
represent
elme yes thank you uh do you
actually do a penalty if they had
paid what they thought they owed at the
beginning but not what they actually
outed in the in the extension so there
are um penalties in statute if they
don't pay proper estimated payments um
one of the ways that they can kind of
have a safe harbor they won't be
penalized if they essentially make
estimated payments equal to their prior
Year's liability because we know that
there's fluctuations in liability of
businesses from year to year and so they
may not be totally aware of what their
ultimate liability will be and so so
long as those estimated payments are
roughly equal to what they paid in the
prior year then they won't be penalized
they do need to make that payment though
that catchup if there is an amount due
that does have to be paid in March or
April depending on the due date that
extension again is only an extension to
file so in filling out that final return
if it find if a taxpayer finds that they
owe additional money there will be
penalties associated with
that representative ORS thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question so
do we have any idea how much money's in
the tube of the prior year taxes to be
not
necessarily um what we're seeing and
we'll talk about this in a little bit
what we're seeing is really a decline in
estimated payments as businesses are
somewhat changing their behavior and how
they're sending estimates to us but we
really won't know what is actually due
for those businesses until those returns
are filed either timely or on extension
and as I just said on extension it's
almost a year after the end of the the
calendar year
let me go to represent Opel and then
represent
Aly thank you Mr chair and thank you for
excuse me thank you for taking my
question commissioner you may be getting
to this later so I may be Jumping the
Shark here but is their historical data
showing what the difference is either
positively or negatively between what
the estimated returns show and then what
you know when they when they finally
file the actual return there's a slide
that we'll get to in a couple minutes I
think that will kind of give you an idea
of of what that looks like um where you
can see kind of how the total revenue is
made up between returns estimates and
extensions follow up M follow um I
should have asked this before but if for
for those of us who are new the acronyms
that you and representative Aly we're
talking about the I'm assuming it's an
end ofe report correct the act for um is
the annual comprehensive financial
report and those are the full audited
financials of the state um and that's
produced by the department of
administrative services along with the
LBA and our external Auditors thank you
I'll be I'll be asking a lot of those no
Acron are you all set represent on me
okay all right thank you okay and then
just on the bottom part or the second
half of this slide um we have the
state's fiscal
year and so you'll see during fiscal
year
2025 we are going to get third and
fourth quarter estimated payments for
calendar year
2024 and then we're going to get first
and second quarter estimated payments
for calendar year
25 we're also going to get
2023 Returns on
extension and we're going going to get
2024 timely filed returns so in the
state's fiscal year we are getting 2023
money 24 money and 25
money all for calendar year taxpayers so
there's a lot of kind of moving pieces
and that's why we do our best to kind of
break down the type of Revenue that
we're receiving um and what that means
when we're presenting to you about um
Revenue
estimates okay moving on to slide 11
this is where you'll see a historical
breakdown of returns estimates
extensions tax notice payments and
refunds so I
would first bring your attention to the
red those are your estimates and so
those are historically and currently the
most significant portion of the revenue
that we
receive your returns and your extensions
are in that kind of Darker blue and
green and so those are the amounts that
were due that did not that were in
excess of the estimates that were
made and so to representative opal's
question you'll see in say fiscal year
22 and fiscal year 23 we we
saw um estimates increase in fiscal year
22 let's just use that as a as a single
data
point estimates in red increased by
year returns and extensions increased by
11.5% and returns increased by
25.2% so those estimates did not cover
the total amount of liability due there
was some amount of money do at that
return point which is in the form of
either the return or an extension
payment to get that seven-month
extension you can see that's different
17 so I think what we've seen in the
past few years and this kind of tracks
with the idea of significant growth in
corporate profits is businesses were
making increased estimated payments and
they still found that they owed money at
too one other point that I would note on
this slide in fiscal year 24 in Orange
are the refunds so this is when a
taxpayer um has paid too much in their
estimated payments and there is some
amount of overpayment they can take that
as a credit carry forward essentially
leave that on their account for future
use or it can be paid back to them in in
the form of a refund what you're seeing
in fiscal year 24 with almost a 90%
increase in refunds is the 500% cap on
their credit carryover liability so
businesses can now only keep on account
up to 500% of their liability so if
their liability was $100 they can't keep
on account more than
$500 if they their overpayment was $600
then we would be refunding $100 to them
so that CCO cap resulted in those
increased refunds is that uh 500% the of
the latest payment that would be 500% of
your prior Year's liability prior okay
correct yep so looking at the most
recent year you can only keep 500% okay
represent elme yes can you tell yet
on
whether this surely isn't just the
people that were taking
refunds because they were over 500% or
is
question as I was assuming that part of
this was people taking refunds earlier
since we were telling them they had
refunds in that extent and they hadn't
been thinking about
24 we
have hold on I just want to make sure I
right we had
71.7
million out of 176
million that were required to be
refunded per the CCO cap so yes there
are taxpayers that choose to take their
overpayment as a refund and there are
taxpayers that may even choose
to not just the forced over 500% but
they may want even more than
that but we've broken it out to identify
71.7 million essentially is what was
required to be refunded based on that
CCO
welcome okay moving on to slide
12 as I mentioned estimates make up the
largest portion of our revenue and so
who pays those
estimates this chart shows in red our
corporations so the majority of our
estimate Revenue comes from
corporations followed by Partnerships
proprietorships and
fiduciaries the percentage percentages
that are contained within the bar chart
are the change from the prior year so in
fiscal year 24 we saw just about a 6%
increase in estimated payments from
corporations a 21% decrease from
Partnerships and a 5.3% decrease from
proprietorships
on slide
13 this just kind of another way to look
at
this for BPT taxpayers about 2.7% of our
filers pay
84.1% of the tax so I'll say that again
less than 3% of the
filers pay 84% of the tax so what you
see in the pie chart on the left is this
is who is filing so these this is a
breakdown of your
filers and I will note here in red is
corporations but in purple you'll see
that's called Water's Edge so these are
our large multinational corporations so
we've kind of made a distinction between
the two so if you're a multinational
entity you are filling out a Waters Edge
return for us so those are the ones in
purple so you'll see 7% of our
filers for BP are Waters Edge but if you
move over to the
right 58% of our money comes from
Water's
Edge looking at corporations 37% of our
filers are
22% another comparison
35% of our filers are
proprietorships but they only pay
4% and this is shown also on the next
slide on page 14 this is an excerpt from
our annual
report we refer to these as the
triangles so those folks that have been
around for a while will hear us talk
about the
triangles so this is just the source of
data for the prior slide but you can see
you get to that very tip of the triangle
those entities that are paying more than
Mill ion Dollar in
BPT they're 2% of the population but
they make up
revenue any questions on
BPT represent
elmy is this
uh
84% on
increasing over time I don't remember it
Vivid say relative to five years
ago I have a year I can do the prior
year pretty quickly so what you have in
front of you is for tax year
22 again because of that delayed that
tax year 22 is the most recently fully
complete tax year for
us if you look at tax year
[Music]
be4 it's going to be very similar we can
go back and look at what it was five
years ago yeah just outside of the
pandemic y exactly pre pre pandemic
yeah well the other the other thing that
changed is that the thresholds for who's
going to file increased so I would guess
that that would lower the number of
proprietorships especially in small
corporations so therefore the numbers
are lower but the the percentage of the
larger filers gets
bigger and that's actually a great Point
what you'll see in this triangle on page
14 you will see you know we had 55 a
half thousand returns filed with a zero
liability because again that threshold
that I read off at the beginning is a
threshold to
file so we receive many returns where no
amount is due be because of deductions
or various other things so that's
something that we you know constantly
like reinforce with new businesses that
you may not owe anything but over a
certain amount you do have an obligation
to file so the the point of zero returns
one
yeah does that answer your question uh
it sort of complicates it okay would you
like to ask your question I'm trying to
figure out if there's any way to analyze
those two separately
but really the increase in the threshold
should just decrease the amount of zero
returns that we receive that's um that's
expect
that's kind of the balance right and
that's why um those thresholds hadn't
been increased in quite some time and so
when the legislature decided to increase
the thresholds they also decided to put
in that adjustment every two years based
on CPI so that we can kind of inflation
adjust those thresholds so that we're
not yeah you know causing people to to
file and when that's not really the
intention so now we automatically update
those thresholds actually an interesting
follow up to that would
be when did it go when did that increase
2023 it's Rec yeah I think I feel like
it was 2023 so the most recent
threshold most recent threshold of
109,000 is going to be the current one
for tax bill periods beginning 1125 so
uh wait minute say that again so so we
do it every two years so the
109,000 but the 2023 is is affected by
that higher threshold correct okay so
um okay yeah so the threshold will
really just
impact the number of zero filers your
original question of kind of what is the
tip of that triangle look like we can
look at that going back to kind of pre-
pandemic um to better understand i' I'd
like to point out to people also that
the
bet we
we fixed that threshold issue in
2011 representative oery suggested that
we ought to do the latest
one remembering what we' done a long
time
okay we good on business profits taxes
as good as we're going to
be there you go you
listening
okay business Enterprise tax so the
current rate for the business Enterprise
tax is
0.55% of the Enterprise Value tax base
which is essentially wages interest paid
and dividends paid and that has been
12322 this is going to be a tax on every
profit or nonprofit Enterprise or
organization with any business activity
within the state except 501 c3s so 501
c3s are the only exception for the
business Enterprise
tax here your filing threshold is
currently at
$298,000 for either gross receipts or
your Enterprise Value tax base and that
was adjusted just for uh recently for
1125 important thing to note about the
bet it is a credit against the
BPT so if you pay $100 in bet and your
BPT liability is
$100 you owe no BPT so it's a one for
one credit against the business profits
tax and that and any unused credit can
be carried forward for 10 years we have
worksheets on our forms that help
that the timing is consistent with the
business profits tax with Partnerships
return partnership returns du on March
15th corporate proprietorship and
fiduciary returns due April 15th and
nonprofit returns due May 15th again
there's an opportunity for a 7-month
extension to file so long as your uh
liability is fully paid and estimates
are made at the same 25% at the same
taxpayers going to slide
16 it's very
consistent with kind of the breakdown
that you saw with the business profits
tax although maybe not as pronounced
here but you have 4.6% so just under 5%
of filers paying 72% of
tax your firers are primarily
proprietorships but the money is
primarily from wat's Edge
corporations on page 17 you have that
same triangle just now with the with
only uh with the business Enterprise tax
and again that's the source for the
information on the prior slide as I said
very consistent in terms of few tax
taxpayers paying the majority of the tax
but I would say it's not as pronounced
tax going to page 18 you'll see kind of
the 10-year Trend when you put bet and
BPT together and as Chris mentioned what
we'll do for Revenue estimating is you
folks will estimate business taxes as a
whole and then we'll work with the LBA
to split that between bet and BPT based
on what we're seeing for most recent
filings um coming in from taxpayers and
then once it split between bet and BBT
it'll do the statutory split into the
general fund and the education trust
fund so you don't need to worry about
estimating one versus the other
especially where they're they interact
so much with the BET being accredit
against the BPT we'll just talk about
business taxes as a
whole and so you can see that we've seen
a significant increase in business taxes
from 2020 all the way to 2023 a slight
decline going into 24 and then we're
seeing that we're behind plan and behind
prior year going into
25 um as I mentioned last week I think
this is largely due to a change in
behavior of the
taxpayers um we are just not seeing them
sending the very large estimated
payments that we had been seeing in the
time from 2020 to 2023
that the economy is still growing
there's still growth within corporate
profits but it's not that extreme growth
that we were seeing during that time of
extreme growth many businesses don't
want to get be caught short on what they
owe at the end of the year even though
they might not be penalized they don't
want to face a large tax bill in April
and so they'll increase those estimated
payments and those estimated payments um
are just not increasing at the rate that
they were previously
we have a couple questions represent
ol thank you commissioner um given the
exuberance in the um previous in the
first Trump
Administration and the amount of Spike
that took
estimate will the downward Trend we've
seen over the last couple of years
continue or will it be a spike or will
it be a
gradual uh let's see how we're going
depending upon whether or not the job
tax
cut great question
so I will say a couple things first the
spike that we saw during um I'll just
say the first adoption the original
adoption of the tax cutting jobs
Act was was due to the fact um or what
was called deemed repatriation so
multinational businesses who had profits
that were um had remained overseas the
federal government said we're going to
tax that and when they did that kind of
freed up the flow of that money back to
the US so New Hampshire we did not tax
that deemed repatriation like the
federal government did we didn't
automatically tax it but we did tax it
when the actual cash came back in the
form of dividends so that's one place
that we saw a significant increase in
Revenue resulting from the tax cut and
jobs act so when those dividends were
actually paid back and there was no
federal liability at that point because
they had already paid the tax on it
freed up the cash to move back
domestically we taxed those dividends
and so that's a way that we saw an
increase in
revenue from the tax cut and jobs act
the second part of your question about
what's going to happen
now is we I mentioned this last week too
but we New Hampshire is what's known as
a static Conformity state so we are
currently tied to the tcja we are
currently tied to the tax cut and jobs
act so in New Hampshire we're not
necessarily concerned about some of
these expiring provision iions because
our our code is the tax cut and jobs
act but if those expiring Provisions are
unexpired
extended put in permanently Etc to the
extent that that generates corporate
profit if that is viewed positively by
the business community and that allows
for their profits to grow we would then
see an increase in our Revenue here in
New Hampshire as a result so anytime
corporate profits grow that's a good
thing but we're not necessarily directly
tied to whether or not the tcja is
extended so that's that's because we're
not uh we have the delay we have the
static Conformity we're not a rolling
Conformity state where we just
automatically pick up the changes at the
federal level so to answer your question
I don't think we'll see the spike that
we did under the first tcja because that
was somewhat unique to that deemed
repatriation and that's already happened
you can't really do it
again and second
um any extension of the tax cut and jobs
act to the extent that that generates
corporate profits would benefit
us as it flows down to the state level
follow up no no she she just said thank
you very much all right representative
opal
yeah I'm sorry
I'm spent a few years at the Pentagon
and got a little confused with fiscal
year versus budget year versus so I'm
just I just want to make sure I
understand we have essentially three
terms now we have a calendar year we
have a state fiscal year July 1 to June
30 correct and then we have in these
documents the tax year and I'm trying to
understand is the tax year based on New
Hampshire's fiscal year or or the or the
entities tax year or how does that work
correct it's the entity's tax year and
so for 90% of our taxpayers that
calendar year and tax year are going to
be the same but for that remaining 10%
who might be on a fiscal year who might
follow the federal fiscal year if
they're a defense contractor Etc then um
we're going to look to so when we say
tax year 22 it's going to be the tax
year that began in 22 so for most the
calendar year and the tax year are one
and the same but if they don't file on a
calendar year basis then we look to the
tax
year representative elme thank you so
let me make sure I totally understand
this on when we were
taxing on returns
dividends
on we were not
taxing uh
them in the interest in dividends area
profits well so we're taxing the the the
foreign dividend so you have a say a US
parent and a foreign Sub in Ireland and
there
was some amount of retained profits in
Ireland over some period of time when
they pay that dividend back they say
Okay parent I'm going to give you
$100 that is taxable for BPT purposes
it's a foreign dividend that's taxable
if the parent then takes that $100 and
distributes it out in the form of
dividends to shareholders then that
would get taxed under
indd except it
wouldn't no not anymore at the time it
did yes that's why I wanted to know
right so it's
the the sub to the parent dividend is
going to be taxed under the BPT and then
the distribution or dividend out to
shareholders it would be taxed under the
etc okay okay okay one last slide on
business taxes um just to be thorough so
there's a few recent business tax
changes that I just wanted to highlight
let's skip the first two for a second
the third one is the CCO cap which we've
talked quite a bit about so you'll see
the 500% of total tax liability for tax
periods ending on or after December 31st
of 2022 that will decrease to 250% and
then down to 100% but those dates have
been kicked out to 1231 29 and 12
3131 so we don't need to worry about it
at this point are you seeing any
Behavior change in businesses I mean of
course they have to know about the
change and I think they given the size
of the refunds that we paid out last
year I think they learned pretty quickly
about the change if they didn't know it
in advance they figured it out when you
know we paid out significantly more in
almost 90% more in refunds than we
typically do and that could also be a
part of the reduced estimated payments
that we're seeing and the reduced
Revenue that we're seeing is the change
in behavior um they don't want to leave
as much on account because they they're
going to have to end up getting it
back um the last bullet just notes the
most recent change to the BPT from 7.6%
to
123123 the first two um bullets I'll
just mention briefly these are changes
to apportionment and so apportionment
matters when you operate in multiple
States how do you take your P of profit
and split it up so let's just say you're
in you operate only in New England and
you have $100 in profit well how much of
that profit is Maine New Hampshire or
Massachusetts apportionment statutes is
how you divide up that profit and so New
Hampshire made a couple of changes
recently one for 12 3121 and then one
for 12
3122 so on 12
3121 we went to what's called
market-based sourcing and so this is
only for the apportionment of services
so if you're an accountant if you're a
lawyer you're providing
Services market-based sourcing looks to
the customer of that
service so if your $100
pie if half of your customers are in
Massachusetts then $50 is going to go to
Massachusetts prior to market-based
sourcing we looked at where that service
was performed and so if you were a New
Hampshire accountant and you did all
your work in New Hampshire but you had
clients in Maine New Hampshire and
Massachusetts we said we don't care
where your clients are if you're
performing the service here you're going
to allocate that profit here so this
shifted to say where is the
customer so that's the first change the
second
um when you look at a business who has
payroll property and sales that's really
ultimately how we're going to distribute
your pie we used to look at all three
factors we looked where's your payroll
where are your people where's your
property and then where are your
sales for 1231 22 now we only look at
sales so we're only looking to wear
again similar to Market base sourcing
where is the ultimate customer and where
is your
sale these changes are consistent with
what other states have done as well and
so that helps to limit taxpayers being
taxed on more than their total pie
because if the states don't abortion the
pi the same way you could end up paying
tax on more than your whole Pi when you
have uniformity and consistency between
states you will never get taxed on more
than 100% of your pie so these were
positive I think for the businesses at
least from a compliance perspective um
it made compliance easier and reduced
that risk that you would be taxed on
more than
100% um it will have some Revenue
impacts it is hard to know the impact of
market-based sourcing because we didn't
have the data previously we knew where
the services were being performed but we
didn't necessarily know where the
customers were so that one was harder to
estimate but for single sales factor
that move away from the three factors to
only using one we had that data and so
it would be some years it would be
Revenue positive some years it would be
Revenue negative it really just
depended um so unfortunately our
estimate for that wasn't the most
um uh I don't want to say accurate it
was accurate but it was variable from
year to year I think we have a question
if you don't mind representative shamber
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
commissioner can you give us a $100
example like you've done with the others
of how
this show Revenue reduction
so with the three Factor
apportionment we're now I if you um had
employees I'll I'll go back okay I'll a
$100 example if you had $25 a payroll in
New Hampshire and 25% of your property
was in New Hampshire and 50% of your
sales were in New
Hampshire that's how we would apportion
it under the three
Factor now all that we look at is those
sales and again it can be Revenue
positive or negative depending on the
year and depending on the taxpayers the
thing to know about single sales factor
is out of those three things payroll
property and sales sales is the most
variable it's harder to get rid of
property or acquire it at this
point changes in in
payroll tend to take time they don't
happen
overnight but changes to your
sales can happen pretty quickly you can
get a new contract you could lose a
contract um and so out of those three
factors sales is where we see kind of
representative
ery thank you commissioner I remember
back in 2021 when we put in the this
this was due to a particularly large
Distributing Company in New Hampshire uh
being taxed for the same sales yes twice
correct uh I guess in New Hampshire and
in Maine correct lesser degree in
Massachusetts
that makes
sense but I'm thinking about a service
only Co
corporation like somebody on Elm Street
in Manchester one of the towers also has
offices in Boston and in
London how does that work if you could
give us an
example
so under Market based sourcing we're
just going to look to where the customer
is
so that complies followup thank you
followup
therefore the taxation policy using this
market-based sourcing comports with
Equitable and proportionate because it's
Equitable for the sales and activity
that takes place within the state and
that also comports with the general uh
IRS regulation of where the activity
takes place is that correct correct
Market based sourcing as I said Market
based sourcing and single sales factor a
portion men are are used widely across
States thank you thank you very much
welcome yes represent elberger thank you
Mr chairman thank you commissioner just
let me try to wrap my head around this
my
my sister and I inherited a investment
person for my parents who got this
person when they lived in
Florida they still are in the the
company is still in Florida I live here
and my sister lives in Georgia yep so
based on this system the company would
be
paying
taxes for the services they provide to
me here in Georgia in New Hampshire and
my sister in Georgia but not for
anything in terms of us in Florida
correct and similarly when we got
someone else doing some tax stuff for us
Massachusetts that company would have
would now only be paying for taxes in
Massachusetts when we were there but not
because they were here correct thank you
y we're just going to we're going to
look to the customer thank you
it's more complicated than that I don't
mean to make it sound really simple
because a portion is one of the most
complex things that we do um but it
really it just all comes down to how do
you divide up that pie where do where
does the profit go where does it get
taxed represent
elme thank you so in my city we have
Nova norus which is from Denmark I
believe it is nor way I can't remember
uh and
on
anything that they basically are selling
for the American market so that's one
thing but we also have uh the largest
laser
uh company in the world uh which is
selling all over the globe now since
we're selling to Brazil brail and China
and a number of other places on that
wouldn't get taxed at all right correct
CU that's where we're going to go to the
edge okay good
okay on to meals and rooms or meals and
rentals however you want to refer to it
so M&R is an 8 and a half% tax on meals
rooms in motor vehicle rentals the tax
is paid by the consumer so you pay it on
your bill when you go out to eat and
collected by the operator that's
remitted to us um on your behalf from
the
operator for doing that work they get to
retain uh 3% of the taxes that they
collect so long as they meet
requirements in terms of filing and
paying the state on a timely
basis the operat ERS file on a monthly
basis 15th day of the month every month
they do that via electronic filing it's
the easiest for most of them and a paper
return is not required um so it's pretty
easy they can use our Granite tax
connect portal and make their monthly um
us on page 21 there are two transfers
that come out of M&R so two amounts
every month month that come out of the
the gross M&R Revenue that we collect
the first is the school building Aid
Debt Service and in fiscal year 25
that's just about 6.6 million we divide
that up across the various months um you
will see that's down from a high of
almost 14 A5 million back in 2012 and we
have one two three four five more years
to go on this building Aid Debt Service
the other transfer that comes out on a
monthly basis is the municipal Revenue
fund so beginning in fiscal year
2022 30% of net M&R from the most
recently completed fiscal year is
distributed to cities in
towns so that started as 100.1 million
in
22 121 million in
23 13.9 and 24 and up to 136 .6 in
25 this is a replacement for a historic
provision in statute which actually was
going to distribute 40% of net M&R
Revenue but that was routinely capped
and so you'll see there's a history down
there from 2013 to
2021 um you see it was capped at 58.8
million then it went up to
63.8 then it went went to
68.8 um and so there was a change in the
statute for for fiscal year 22 that
reduced the amount that is going to go
to cities and towns from 40% to 30 but
essentially removed that cap and that
money goes on a monthly basis into a
dedicated
fund so that comes out every month um
but when you're comparing fiscal year 21
to 22 Revenue you just need to know that
there's $100 million that came out and
went into a dedicated fund so it's not
comparison on page 22 and we talked
about this a little bit last week this
is just the breakdown between meals
rooms and motar
vehicles so you'll see for 2020 to 2024
on average 80% of the revenue is from
meals 18% from rooms and then 2% from
motor vehicles and I will note that
motor vehicle rentals are only motor
vehicle rentals this doesn't include
snowmobiles ATVs boats anything like
that it's it's really just the the motor
vehicles that you're renting at a car um
Agent on page
23 this includes a breakdown of tax comp
components by
County so first at the top you will see
how M&R kind of breaks down by county
and you'll see that the largest counties
are Rockingham Hillsboro and
marac at the bottom chart what you'll
see is for each County how the revenue
breaks down between meals rooms and
Motor
Vehicles so on the left hand side you'll
see straford and Rockingham straford is
92% of the revenue is from meals for
Rockingham it's
89% going to the other end to Carol and
coaz meals are only 66% and
54% but they have the highest rooms at
34% and 46%
the other thing to not is Hillsboro
you'll see by far has the largest motor
vehicle rentals and those are the car
rentals at the
airport the one thing I'll note before I
take questions on this is um over the
years there's been a lot of requests if
we can break down M&R Revenue by
Town um and part of that I think is
driven from that 30% that goes back to
cities and towns that goes back based on
population um some folks have wondered
whether that should be returned based on
the amount of M&R Revenue that's
generated in each town and long story
short we cannot provide the M&R data by
town for a couple of reasons one we
allow for Consolidated filing so if you
own a number of Dunkin Donuts franchises
across the state or you own a restaurant
or a hotel that has multiple locations
you may you have to have a license for
every location but we allow you to pick
one of those licenses and file
everything
together um also for some of our large
online travel companies that rent out a
lot of rooms or a lot of short-term
rentals they have a license for all of
their locations across the state but
that license typically has one address
on it cuz they're going to be a
Consolidated filer the other reason is
we get into cities and towns that maybe
have only two
restaurants and if we disclosed that
information for that town and you knew
what you were paying because you owned
one of those restaurants suddenly you
know exactly how much your competitor is
making so we cannot break M&R down by
Town um the county level is kind of as
far down as we'll go
but I will note you know that some that
these numbers do have Consolidated
filings in it so they are probably a
little bit skewed to that extent but um
it's not as skewed as it would be if we
went down to the municipal level so
happy to take questions on &r
breakdown representative Opel thank you
Mr chair again thank you commissioner um
just for clarification the um the tax on
rental cars or rental of
vehicles that
includes um if I rent a a truck from
Ryder to move some furniture that that
would be included in it yep and they
would collect that from you on your bill
and remit it to us okay so that's an
example where if if somebody had three
or four Rider franchises one was in nsha
one was in Manchester and one was in
Lebanon yep it would be hard to they
wouldn't they would report it as a
Consolidated filer as one from one and
so so the only way we would be able to
get that breakdown is to then be able to
require it under
statute and that is a significant
undertaking um for those operators you
know filing Consolidated is much simpler
and easier for them especially because
they're filing on a monthly basis
they're filing 12 of these a year and if
you're a Consolidated filer with 25
locations 12 time 25 is not fun um in
terms of of the undertaking so um
there's no way to currently provide that
data based on the information that we
have the only way would be to have a
legislative change that would require it
and my apologies Mr chairman I think I
snuck a followup in there without sure
without requesting representative Spar
thank you chair uh the 3% uh commission
that is there is that um what's the
intention or purpose of that and is that
typical uh among other states and sure
that's a great question so I think the
intention and the purpose there is that
they are kind of doing work on behalf of
the state um we also have a commission
with our real estate transfer tax for
the counties and we'll talk about that
in a minute but in the case of the
counties and then on the operators here
they're collecting the money on behalf
of the state um and then you know
remitting it on a monthly basis it is
common you will see commissions um in
other states for sales tax um or other
similar taxes to this there have been
conversations over the years about um is
3% the right number that's what it's
been for quite some time um and and
again the only way that they can retain
that commission is if they file and pay
on time so if you don't file and pay on
time um and if you don't file
electronically in most cases you're not
going to be able to keep that commission
so the electronic filing and the
collection by The Operators um really
reduces the work that the state would
okay okay thank you um on page 24 this
is just you know your your 10-year trend
of
M&R what you can see between fiscal year
21 and fiscal year 22 is a
decline that is the result of the
municipal Revenue transfer because this
is going to be just your general fund
Revenue so um and then the the increase
from 22 23 4 that is generally the trend
that we be we have been seeing um that
M&R has been performing quite well but
just wanted to call out what looks like
a decline is a decline to the general
fund but not necessarily a decline in
tax
tax again we talked through this a
little bit last week but we'll um cover
it again really the to the tobacco tax
it's kind of three taxes in
one you have your tax on a pack of
cigarettes which is $1.78 per pack of 20
or
$223 for 25 cigarettes and that is tax
based on a stamp that's stuck on the
bottom of the
pack there's also a tax on other tobacco
products that are not ecigarettes this
would be your loose tobacco your chewing
tobacco Etc that is 65 5.03% of the
wholesale sales
price and then we did have an ecigarette
tax go into effect on January 1st of
2020 and that is uh taxed differently
based on whether it's a closed system or
an open system so a Clos system would be
the ecigarette or vape that looks like a
pen everything's contained in one when
the liquid is gone you throw it out and
that is taxed on 30 cents per milliliter
on the volume of liquid that's contained
within the closed
system an open system is where you buy
typically just the liquid separately and
you have um a device that heats the
liquid um and you don't throw that
device out every
time that is taxed at 8% of the
wholesale sales price of the
liquid premium cigars are exempt from
Taxation and this is a tax upon the cons
consumer but pre-collected and paid by
the wholesaler although there's no
case
um when to file and pay so for
cigarettes that are sold in packages of
20 or 25 the wholesalers purchase rules
of stamps and affix them
to the product and they just come back
to us to buy more stamps when they need
them and for other tobacco products and
for ecigarettes then the wholesaler
report and pays that tax on a monthly
month on page 26 we have a question on
that uh yes represent thanks we have a
problem in that the ecigarettes
uh there are apparently an awful lot of
the ecigarettes like about 90% are
coming from China on container ships
which are not uh in
expected on their way in and so they do
not show up uh the
wholesalers that usually do the tobacco
products apparently are not uh acquiring
them or if they are they are illegally
requiring them and therefore they aren't
filing them and there is a bill in that
is trying to do something about this I'm
not sure the final version works very
well but I'm on it
so
on they they are the young people are
doing much more with ecigarettes than
they
are with the older type and and the
older people seem to be moving towards
it too
so um correct we'll talk about the
breakdown between ecigarettes and U more
traditional products but if the first
part of your question was getting at how
does the department in Ure that tax is
paid I think that might have been where
you were going with that um so what we
do is we go into tobacco retailers and
we ask the retailer for copy of their
invoices from the wholesaler that shows
that tax has been paid if they don't
have an invoice showing that tax is paid
we seize the
product um and when that happens the
retailer then comes in for a hearing and
they have the opportunity to present
invoices that maybe their clerk couldn't
find at the time or whatever the case
may be we schedule a hearing they come
in they're allowed to present us with
evidence to show that the tax wasn't p
pa paid and if they can't then it's
considered contraband it's seized um and
we go through the process of attempting
to destroy it so we go into tobacco
retailers um and do tobacco retail
checks on a weekly basis um and when we
find product that we don't believe is
taxed we take it how one second how long
do you hold it until it's destroyed so
we've been holding some product for
quite some time but given the recent
increase in product um coming from China
and not going through the proper
holesale channels we've come across
quite a bit of product that um is
contraband and we are have essentially
ex exceeded our storage capability and
we are working before the end of the
fiscal year to destroy um the product
that we have on hand it's not easy um it
is hazardous waste um the lithium
batteries that are contained within the
ecigarette Clos systems and the liquid
is also hazardous so it's um it's a bit
of an undertaking and there's only
certain companies that are able to do
it repres elme yes s the followup on the
other allegation that was made was that
since it did not go through
inspection and since these come as open
system
bottles on and they have no markings on
them even in Chinese that say what's in
them on is there any way to uh check
what the
ingredients not necessarily so there's
I'll I guess I'll frame it this way
these products can be Contraband for one
of two reasons in my mind one is their
Contraband from the tax perspective in
that the tax has not been paid they also
can be considered contraband because
they're not on the FDA approved list of
ecigarette products so I'm not in charge
of enforcing the FDA approved cigarette
products I'm only looking at it from the
tax perspective but you're correct that
there's there's really two risks there
in terms of these products they may not
have the tax properly paid and they may
not have passed the fda's um requirement
for sale of these
products is does the FDA get it all
first so it all goes through the FDA
first no no some of it comes directly to
New Hampshire yep okay
yep so some of these retailers can
purchase product directly from China um
and that's some of what we've seen and
so if it hasn't gone through a licensed
whor then it doesn't have the proper tax
paid on it and is also probably
Contraband from the fda's point of view
as well okay representative is that a
followup uh just a a final followup if I
or others put in a bill next year to
test some of this stuff before it's
destroyed would we be able to do that or
is this totally in the realm of
FDA which hasn't been moving very
quickly on this
stuff I don't know I I mean I don't know
the answer to
that directly
we we like I said we have the Contraband
from the tax perspective and the the FDA
doesn't necessarily know what we have um
because it's Contraband for tax purposes
and it was not seized as Contraband um
under the
FDA I just like to add that it is not uh
in Chinese on these bottles apparently
China there probably questionable
ingredients
maybe uh okay we have a lot of questions
representative
oing very good
uh regarding the product that is on the
FDA list that is confiscated for tax I
do not it seems to me we should be able
to make some money off of
that that thought has crossed my mind um
I
don't I will say that's not the majority
of what we
have um typically the the products that
are on the
fda's approved list are from reputable
well-known manufacturers who understand
the supply chain and the product is
properly
taxed um the thought the other issue I
guess with this is it's very expensive
to destroy this product um we're lucky
that we there we have found money in our
budget to do it it will require us to go
to both fiscal and GNC in order to move
money around to make the
payments um so I have thought
through you know it doesn't seem fair to
us that we're doing our job and we're
incurring you know $150,000 Bill to
destroy this product um but I just I
don't think any of these
retailers would have the funds to be
able to pay
it anyway I I don't know there's not a
good solution I guess is my point um and
a lot of some cases this product um much
of it is
expired um and not something that we
want back out uh for people to
consume follow up uh thank you Mr
chair specifically however if it's if
it's re sailable yep is there a
mechanism or can there be a mechanism
within
Dr as uh High does with their Surplus
so-called Surplus equipment sure um
there is the to dispose of salable
product sure there's currently no
mechanism but potentially as part of
bills that go through the process we
could think about um that as a solution
I will just say there's nothing I can
say pretty confidently there is nothing
that we have right now that I would view
as salable okay quick follow okay quick
if um if you see something where that
would be appropriate would you please
let uh us know thank you all right
represent op um thank you Mr chairman um
in this uh commissioner that my question
actually relates I think to something
that representative ol was getting at
I'm
wondering
um what happens to a retailer or seller
um uh you know if if if it happens one
time where they're selling
untaxed or even you know just they've
gone outside the system
um is you know what happens to that
seller and then I'm assuming if there's
more than one time that it occurs that
and that this may not be in the purview
of Dr but I'm assuming that it is in the
purview of the state you're correct so
there are um penalty Provisions within
the statute and then the ability to
ultimately revoke a license if we see
repeat
offenses and so fortunately um one time
is usually enough to teach them um and
so we don't knock on wood don't see a
ton of repeat offenders um but there are
mechanisms in statute to address
that follow up I'm I'm wondering in the
case
of that situation if there if that fee
or
if if there's some relationship between
making them pay for the destruction or
or at least pay some
percentage I think that's something
we're going to have to think about
because it is it is so expensive but
it it's so cost prohibitive to them as
well that I think to your point we might
have to find the balance
there um there was a question over
here okay not
anymore okay okay I guess we're good
thank you okay um on page 26 this shows
you the breakdown
of cigarettes to other tobacco products
so cigarettes um from fiscal year 21 to
24 on average were 86% of the revenue
that was collected and other tobacco
14% page 27 shows you just the history
of just the tobacco tax stamp Revenue
um as Chris was alluding to earlier and
we have another slide coming up that
talks about other states um but you'll
see in fiscal year 20 to 21 that pretty
significant increase in the consumption
of cigarettes um that's really twofold
as Chris mentioned covid um isolation
and high anxiety times uh it's not
really conducive to reduced smoking um
so we saw an increase in usage during
that time um also there were bans of
certain products in other states which
drove people to New Hampshire to
purchase products that we had available
here that they couldn't purchase in
other states going from fiscal year 21
to 24 you do see that kind of declining
consumption um and declining Revenue
associated with tobacco tax stamps on
page 28 we show the history of other
tobacco products so your traditional
other tobacco products your loose
tobacco chewing tobacco pipe tobacco
that's going to be in the blue and then
ecigarettes um starting with January 1
of 2020 are in that yellowish orange
color and so you can see that
ecigarettes um the revenue associated
with that has grown in the past few
years so we are seeing as representative
Aly mentioned that shift from the use of
more traditional um cigarettes to
ecigarettes
looking at the 10year trend on page
29 you can see leading into the pandemic
um and folks that were on the have been
on the committee for a while will
remember we saw a pretty consistent
year-over-year decline in the tobacco
tax that increased from 1920 into 21 due
to covid and the ban of products in
other states and then we're seeing a bit
of a reset back to um normal and Below
on page 30 I think we can answer a
little bit of the questions that have
been asked about tobacco tax rates in
other states and how that impacts the
amount of Revenue that we see here so on
the leftand side you will see comparison
of tax rates for nearby States you will
see that we are ranked 26th in the
nation but we have surrounding states
such as New York Rhode Island
Connecticut Massachusetts and burm that
10 on the right you will see a ranking
um for smuggled cigarettes consumed as a
percent of total cigarettes consumed so
this is basically saying we are first in
the nation
for um cigarettes that are purchased
state so that contributes to the revenue
um that we see and if you were to
actually take the number of cigarettes
that we essentially sell every year and
try to look at that on a per capita
basis for New Hampshire we'd probably
all be long gone there's no way we could
consume all of those so most of most of
what's purchased here is um consumed out
of state all right representative boards
thank you Mr chair thank you
commissioner so the uh forbidden
products in other states I guess would
be like menthol cigarettes and that type
of thing correct so other states have
banned um menthol cigarettes flavored
product flavored ecigarettes um and so
that has d uh driven those folks to New
Hampshire at least initially to purchase
their product they may find other ways
to purchase it such as over the Internet
um Etc but at least initially when those
bands go into effect we see a bump um in
in our Revenue here okay thank you
followup and so
uh if we were to increase the tax on
cigarettes you know pack of 20 whatever
from Buck 78 to uh I think I read
something recently possibly 278 a pack
how might that influence what I'm seeing
here for New Jersey and Maine I mean are
we looking at a potential loss of
Revenue so I think it would be a balance
between the additional Revenue by the
higher tax rate balanced with the
potential reduction in the purchase of
cigarettes from out of state consumers
here and it it would be kind of the
balance between the two I don't know
that it would immediately result in a
decrease
um even if we went to what was above um
you know Maine or New Jersey just
because of that additional dollar so it
it would just be the
balance thank you and if I can just
clarify I did misspeak slightly we're
not the first state we're the fifth
state so um when you look at the
rankings on the right New Hampshire is
45th presumably out of 50 representative
om yeah thank you do you have any uh
data commissioner on the per capita uh
use of tobacco some national rates that
we can look at for Trends we could we
can get that information um I think
there's some additional information in
this report that by the tax Foundation
that's called cigarette taxes and
cigarette smuggling um by state we can
we can get that report to you um and
kind of pull out some highlights from it
in terms of per capita um usage and that
thing okay if no more questions we'll
head on to the Rett tax okay so real
estate transfer tax again we talked
about this last week and I know you
heard from a lot of folks during the
year economic two days of economic
briefings about the housing market um so
I won't totally beat a dead horse but
hopefully just provide a little bit more
context um so this is a tax on the sale
granting in transfer of real property or
interest in Real Property the tax is
imposed on both the buyer and the seller
at a rate of 75 cents per $100 of the
price or consideration of the sale as I
mentioned earlier um this is essentially
paid by buying stamps which are affixed
to the deed and that is done from the
register of deeds in the county where
the property is located for doing that
work um the register of deeds retains 4%
of the face value of the stamps that are
sold in the
county each buyer and seller file a
declaration of consideration and an
inventory property transfer within 30
days each register shall remit the taxes
collected to the department on a monthly
basis typically on the 10th so by the
15th or so we usually have the majority
of our um real estate transfer tax
revenue um in the door the only
exception to that is real estate holding
company transactions those don't go
through the county those are um reported
to the Dr and paid to the Dr um directly
so when you have a change in the amount
of um in a real real estate holding
company transactions those come directly
to
us and we watch for those on a monthly
basis and we will note in the revenue
Focus if there's significant real estate
holding company transactions um so that
you understand um that it's different
transactions um looking at fiscal year
2024 share of total transactions and
total revenue you will see that the
majority of the transactions occur in
Hillsboro and Rockingham County and they
also have the majority of the revenue no
real surprise there but just so folks
could so that you could see um the
activity in each of your counties I
thought would be
helpful and then on page 33 looking at
the 10year
trend um you'll see from 2015 to 2020 we
were pretty consistent um year of a year
increase obviously um the interest in
buying homes in New Hampshire um during
the pandemic so 20 to 21 and 21 to 22
pretty significant
increases I would note that in 2021
209.000 that was a new high since 2025
um but the inventory isn't there and the
sales aren't happening um we are seeing
a bit of a recovery in
2025 so I think we you know will kind of
level out here um but again in 2024 even
at 183.2 million you know that's almost
30 million more or more than 30 million
more than where we were in 2019 so we
just had a really great couple years of
R and now it's kind of right sizing a
bit Yeah r pres ol was just uh pointing
out that if we draw a line is that what
you're going to say no I from 2020 to
2024 it's a continue up the slope is
very consistent so if you throw out the
excess data of 20 uh
2122 it's interesting yes agreed do you
have any uh uh information from either
Realtors or the uh uh 10 counties or 11
act no 10 counties um
Registries regarding the number of refid
that are taking place or you know the uh
the extensions the subprime tent
occasionally offers if you can't make
this payment we're just going to roll it
on to the end of your term of your
mortgage so that a 30-year mortgage
becomes a 35 40 45 50e mortgage do you
have any of that data around I don't at
the moment it's something that we
possibly could look into because that
would
certainly potential or would influence a
homeowner's decision about if and when
they might want to sell their home right
if um if they're having trouble making
payments um you know maybe they would
you know want a downsize if they can
even afford to do that you know or the
price that they'd be looking to sell
their home would need to um cover the
The increased mortgage um or increased
time for which they are making payments
on that mortgage representative follow
up yes thank you yes I I understand that
that it as I was reminded it does not
affect R but it does affect
bankruptcies uh and with the strict
bankruptcy laws that we have now as
opposed to two decades
ago does this affect the ability of a
consumer to purchase a property I think
the
biggest um difficulty is just the
properties need to be up for sale I I
think it's I think it's an inventory I
think in the first case it's an
inventory problem and in the second case
it's an affordability problem and I
think that's pretty consistent with what
you heard last week that's what that's
at least what we're seeing from the data
that we're looking at thank you okay
thank you
sure okay okay we are going to very
quickly walk through the interest and
dividends tax just because I wanted to
be thorough um and there will be um
there is revenue from indd in 25 and we
will come to you with an estimate for a
small amount of indd Revenue in 26 and
even a smaller amount in 27 so because
we will have a little bit of Revenue I
just wanted to make sure everyone was
aware of what the IND is so the IND has
been repealed um effective January 1st
of
2025 um we are in the process starting
today of mailing out 90,000 letters um
making sure folks know that the tax is
repealed that they need to file their
final or the their return for 2024
that's going to be due in April but they
should not be making estimated payments
for
2025 um so we're doing our best to
communicate all of that so that we don't
collect any money that is not due to the
state U I have a question on that point
I mean is is it necessary to send all
those out because when someone goes to
file 2025 there won't be a
form but you would you would think
[Laughter]
that that assumes that one would want to
use the correct form um that doesn't
always happen um so certainly you know
anybody utilizing a CPA or an an
accountant um or an enrolled agent to
prepare their taxes they're very well
aware we have not produced 2025 forms we
have various internal processes in place
um to do our very best to not cash that
check if it is for a 2025 indd estimated
payment uh we have letters ready to go
to send it right back to you we're not
even going to cash it um some of that
will get cash um uh or payments will be
made because people do have the ability
to just kind of make a payment to us
because we are charged with collecting
money and we don't want to make it too
difficult for you to to make a payment
um but we're trying to do our best to
make sure that we don't collect money
that is would be due for 2025 that makes
sense but it made me think if somebody
is paying and they don't put on their
check what quarter it's for y then you
you have a conundrum most too correct
yeah correct and you know we are all
creatures of habit and we are all um
overstimulated on a daily basis and so
folks are just in the habit of making
that you make that return payment in
April and you send your estimate payment
right along with it um and so we're just
doing our very best to make sure people
are
aware um the threshold for the interest
in dividends tax was
$2,400 a year or 4,800 for joint filers
and there was also an exemption for
residents that were 65 or older blind or
disabled before their 65th birthday the
timing follows very similarly with um
your personal income tax at a federal
level so returns are due April 15th
there is an automatic extension to file
but not to pay and quarterly estimates
are due April 15th June 15th September
15th and January 15th so I will not that
is why we did not send out the letters
until starting today because there is an
estimated payment that is due January
15th that is still due even though the
tax is repealed because that estimated
payment is final payment for the prior
year so we did want to limit
confusion as much as we
can sounds good um on page 35 just a
breakdown of indd indd is primarily paid
by individuals and Joint
filers and distributions in tax year 22
made up the largest portion um of the
tax but interestingly on page
36 we kind of went back 10 years years
and showed the breakdown between
distributions dividends federally tax
exempt interest income and interest and
you'll see especially in 2023 that's a
pretty large portion in green so that
interest income is a result of the
higher interest rates that we've seen um
so a good portion of the growth in indd
in tax year 2023 is due to increased
interest
rates on page 37 just looking at the
10-year Trend again we've seen pretty
significant growth in the past um year
or so as interest rates have
increased
um but this is repealed so we'll have
some some lingering money as um people
do not always pay on time we do still
have audit and collection Authority and
so we will make sure that the tax is
fully wrapped up so there will be some
Revenue that does come in in fiscal
on page 38 moving on to communication
Services
tax again we talked about this last week
Communications Communication service
providers are responsible for collecting
and remitting the tax so this would be
tacked on to your cell phone bill this
is um comes in on the 15th of every
month looking at the 10-year trend on
page
39 we've seen a decrease in CST over the
past 10 years that's really due to a
couple of things first fewer landlines
for a while folks had a landline and a
cell phone now many people have given up
those
landlines and then as we talked about
last week kind of modern pricing on your
cell phone bill um the tax is on two-way
Communications but not on internet
access
so as more and more of your cell phone
bill is attributed attributed to data
and your use of surfing the web checking
your email that's going to decrease the
CST where we have seen a bit of an
increase is in um the use of VoIP and
video conferencing coming out of the
pandemic um that is taxable and so we've
seen some increase
okay so that kind of wraps up we've got
a number of slides to go but um that
wraps up basically the larger taxes that
you're going to be um
estimating I have a couple of quick
slides on the Medicaid enhancement tax
and then the nursing facility quality
assessment so these are not going to be
general fund revenues these are going to
be um dedicated funds or restricted
revenues so the first um is a Medicaid
enhancement tax and that's
5.4% on net patient services revenues um
of hospitals the taxes paid by General
hospitals that provide both inpatient
and outpatient
services and the Met has a little bit of
a funky um tax period it's for the
12-month period beginning July 1 and
ending June 30 and the tax is based on
the F Hospital's fiscal year end
that occurred within the calendar year
end of that taxable
period it's
complicated I have to draw it out every
time what it really means is there's a
bit of delay probably even more
pronounced than what we see with
business taxes between the revenues of
the hospital and it being reflected in
met Revenue so each hospital has to file
a non-binding estimate honored before
January
15th so I can tell you for this year
which will be for the taxable period
ending June 30
2025 we received non-binding estimates
of
$348.00
million the budget assumed
$276.5
million so the estimates non-binding
estimates were
348.50 and the operating budget assumed
276.50
two questions yeah you you go further on
and say this goes into the uncompensated
that's to pay for Littleton and and the
smaller hospitals sure that require
assistance for their Emergency
Services yeah so we'll talk uh I
understand that but in a couple slides
the hospital Corporation is paying this
on each patient
Bill the hospital is paying this on on
what is deemed net Patient Service
statute and so there's deductions for
uncompensated care there's a deductions
for charity care Etc so it's basically
they're going to pay the difference
between uncompensated pay and charity
pay um so they'll that that's why it's
net Patient Service Revenue so it's it's
really a tax on the actual money that
they've received so it's a business
profits tax on a
nonprofit
sure um looking at the 10year trend of
met on page 41 um it generally has
increased um the slope there is pretty
consistent with the exception of 20 to
21 and this is when a lot of outpatient
services were not happening during covid
so if you kind of ignore that little
blip that slope is pretty
consistent in terms of our role um as
representative ery was mentioned so they
file their non um binding estimated
payment with us we notify um DHHS of
that amount I'm going to do that this
afternoon and then the hospitals will
pay um their met to us on January 15 or
excuse me April 15th the Met is then
deposit ited directly into the
uncompensated care and Medicaid fund
that is established in statute and then
the commissioner of HHS is responsible
for Distributing that those funds in
accordance um with disproportionate
share Hospital payments or dish payments
is sometimes how you may hear them
referred to in other um Medicaid
expenditures and then it is up to Dr to
audit those returns and collect any
additional met that's owed yes we have
another question repres all okay you're
up you're auditing the returns from the
hospitals to to yourself correct who
audits the disposition of the
funds that would likely distribution of
the distribution of the funds that would
likely
um fall to um either the LBA or the
Auditors um the state's external
Auditors that that money was spent spent
appropriately Accord the statute thank
you have another question represent Aly
can I have a comment you may as long as
it's okay not too long
on this uh medic Medicaid um enhancement
uh used to be called medas scam we when
I came in we were not allowed to use
that that name outside of a closed room
uh but the feds caught up with it about
after about 15 years I forget exactly
when uh and imposed regulations and then
imposed more regulations and that's
what's in our statutes that they have to
abide
by okay I think we can continue okay
thank you um the next three pages 43 44
and 45 are for the nurs in facility
quality
assessment think met but for nursing
homes very similar operates in a very
similar way so I won't go into too much
detail um on page
44 you'll see pretty significant
increase in NF QA from 22 23
24 this is probably going to Trend in
that direction we have an aging
population in New Hampshire higher
utilization of nursing homes means more
NF QA
and then on page 45 similar to met this
is going to be um money that's directly
deposited into the nursing facility
trust fund and it's the responsibility
of the commissioner of DHHS to expend
those
funds you have another question yes
Robi I just a quick uh look from 2015 to
uh
2024 that's pretty watch uh a straight
line uh why the outlayer with the
23 are you looking at NF QA nqa Revenue
I'm seeing it kind of go up and down you
drew a straighter line than I did I drew
a straight
line um this will just again fluctuate
by um utilization of nursing homes so
like 20 to 21 to 22 you see that go down
a bit this is where you're also going to
have potential with um covid with
patients being hit harder in nursing
homes than other places also um the
ability to staff facilities you know to
a level where you can have increased
number of patients it all kind of goes
together that make sense that's fair
okay yes represent El me this is a
question uh is um our our Assisted
Living places included in
this so this is going to be um nursing
facilities as well as facilities
licensed as specialty hos hospital and
certified to receive federal
reimbursement as a nursing facility so I
know we have a variety
of um living facilities and this is not
my area of expertise but the definition
in the statute is essentially if if
you're certified to receive federal
reimbursement as a nursing facility then
you would be subject to the nursing
facility quality assessment thank
you okay okay page 46 utility property
tax so this again we talked about a bit
last week we got a couple of questions
um so this is a tax on utility property
at
$660 per thousand of value the Dr sets
the values as of December 1st and that's
based on um the value from the previous
April
first utility property taxpayers will um
make estimated payments to us and then
any amount that is Due based on their um
new assessment on December 1st that is
due to us by January
15th on page 47 you can see some slight
Vari in the tax although we've been
between essentially 40 um and 47 million
over the past few years here um and this
is driven by the number of properties
that qualify as utility property and how
they are generally
performing um in terms of uh their
profitability I have a quick question
does the do the towns get any tax or is
this totally just a only state only the
state can tax the utilities this is the
state's assessment on these utilities
the town will tax this the towns and
municipalities will tax this property as
well okay um and so it is taxed at the
state level it goes the money goes
directly into the education trust fund
and then these properties are not
subject to the Statewide education
property tax or the swept so looking at
you know my residential property um in
the town that I live in I am going to
pay the swept and I'm going to pay my
local property tax for these Utilities
in my same town they're going to pay a
local property tax and they're going to
pay the upt essentially in lie of the
swept so they wouldn't pay the
swept yes
represent speculation pending
legislation yes generators yes are
currently paying the upt correct so if
the pending legislation uh goes
forward their contribution to this will
be reduced but it will be be picked up
correct if they become exempt from the
upt whatever um they're paying in will
come out of this
tax that will then make them subject to
the swept and they will then contribute
to the 363 3 million statutory amount of
swept there unless there is a specific
addition to the swept of the amount that
they paid in upt it won't necessarily be
made up
elsewhere well yeah but they'll be
contributing to the swept which will be
lowering the swept for everybody
else makes sense thank you ma'am
represent
elme just a clarification are we talking
about those little itty bitty generators
that no we're talk dams dams we're
talking about power large power
generators right not your little home
yes okay we're gonna go through the next
couple of slides pretty quickly it's not
Revenue that you need to estimate it's
just falls under dr's purview um the
first is the railroad tax it um
generates less than
$300,000 a year relatively small but Dr
um determines the value and is taxed
somewhat similarly to
upt on page 49 we have local property
taxes so this is where I was just
talking about the
swept the Statewide education property
tax the department is charged with
setting the swept rate for each
municipality so that the state generates
um a minimum of $363 million every year
we do that by rounding to the nearest
half cent so that um even with that
rounding we generate slightly more than
the 363 just because of
rounding Dr also oversees local property
taxes so we set the rates the local
rates in all of the
municipalities um so we set the local
rate the school rate the county rate and
the swept rate so you have us to thank
for your local property tax bill as well
Mr chairman yes we have a question re
Elber um I'm a little confused here I
thought that in Nashua the property tax
rate is set by the board of
alderman we they set the
spend and then we set the actual rate so
we do the math between the total value
in the town and the total spend we put
those two
together when you're going to be the
unpopular tax collector you might as
well just do it
all yes representative yeah but that's
the swept is separate from
the correct so we set the swept warrant
we tell the towns what they need to
collect in swept and then we set the
other rates based on the spend um and
the valuation that the town provides to
us so the town follow up so again the
towns or cities municipalities set their
own they they right they they provide us
with the values and they provide us with
scam the swept is
virtual uh it's included in your tax
your property local property tax bill on
when you pay it you pay the swept
yourself it's not coming from the state
the state never sees it correct the
swept is um paid by property owners and
on your tax bill and it is retained
locally so rather than the
municipalities sending that money to the
state and then sending it back to the
municipalities it is is currently um
retained at the municipal level there
are numerous bills that address the
swept this session
yes okay okay two other local taxes that
Dr um helps to administer is the gravel
tax and the timber tax also referred to
as Sticks and Stones within
Dr um so gravel tax there is a 2 cent
per cubic yard of
Earth when it's excavated it is taxable
we help the municipalities administer
that we have a gravel expert on staff
there is also a Timber tax where the tax
rate is 10% of the stumpage value at the
time of cutting again assessed and
payable to the local assessing officials
but we have some Tree Experts and
logging experts on staff that assist the
municipalities with doing that
on page 52 this is similar chart that I
provided last week but just gives you a
breakdown of the timing of revenues that
Dr
collects so I think the easiest thing is
to go all the way to the bottom which
looks at the breakdown between the first
half of the year and the second half of
the year so at this point we have
revenues through
December so half the year is over so for
business taxes over the 2014 to 2024
period history has tell told us that
we've collected 43% of the revenue for
the year and that 57% of the revenue is
going to come in between January and
June why is the second half of the year
more we still have two estimated
payments in the second half like the
first half but we also have all of those
return and extension payments in March
and April so more than half of the
revenue is still to come for business
for M&R we've probably already collected
more than half of the revenue
um the best months for um M&R revenue is
really July August September October
those nice summer months coming into the
fall M&R Trails off a bit in the winter
mud season's tough um so we've probably
seen more than half of M&R come in so
far this year tobacco split just about
5050 indd again it's been repealed but
this is one I just like to
highlight um where that estimated
payment is not made until January that
final estimated payment you have the
vast majority of your revenue for for
indd collected in the second half of the
year and then lastly for r r kind of
looks similar to M&R we have probably
already collected more than half of R
for the year those same nice June July
or July August September October those
are nice months um for home buying and
selling as well and we go into a bit of
on page 53 is just a list of resources
if you're dying for more information you
can always call me um or if you're
having trouble
sleeping um our annual report is
available on our website we have a
transparency page which has some nice
graphs and statistics we provide daily
revenue updates a tax expenditure report
and you can always sign up for our list
serve to get all of the great news that
I just want to take a couple minutes to
do a little bit of a preview for the
next time that you see us um with
respect to revenues you'll see us for
bills but the next time you see us with
respect to revenues we'll actually be
working with Chris to do Revenue
estimates and so the way that we do this
is we
typically estimate where we believe the
current fiscal year will end so where
will fiscal year 25 end
and then we look at what the growth
rates will be from 25 to 26 and then 26
to
27 so 26 and 27 we're only going to talk
growth
rates where we need to make the decision
is where 25 is going to end and the way
that we do that is we run a few
different
scenarios namely five we look at what
fiscal year 25 plan is for each tax type
we look at the sustaining percent versus
plan so if the first 6 months of the
year we were 5% ahead of plan let's
assume we remain 5% ahead of plan for
the rest of the year where does that get
us then we do the same thing but we
compare it to Prior year so if we're 10%
ahead of Prior year let's assume we
remain 10% ahead of Prior year for the
rest of the
year then our last two scenarios is we
take year-to date and we say let's just
say we equal plan for the rest of the
year and then let's take year to date
and say let's just say we equal prior
year for the rest of the year so we put
all of these five scenarios together and
what we'll do for you is we'll kind of
hone all of those into a high low range
so for instance if plan if we are
outperforming plan we're not even going
to give you that as one of the scenarios
because it's just not realistic so we'll
kind of give you a realist sck high and
low for where we think 25 is going to
end and then we'll give you a high and
low for 26 for growth rates and a high
and low for
27 as Chris mentioned we don't need to
account for pending legislation that
will be done with within the Surplus
statement and then we will talk about
any impact of current law although I
don't think there's a lot that we'll
really need to address there most of the
changes are already in a effect and I
don't other than the repeal of indd I
don't see a lot of impacts of any
current law that we haven't already felt
but we'll walk through that with you if
there are any at the time that we do
Revenue
estimates and then lastly in the P last
couple minutes um Chris mentioned rims
as part of um his discussion earlier so
folks that are new to the committee I
just wanted to give everybody kind of an
overview you'll hear us talk about rims
um so rims was a big deal um it is our
Revenue information management system Dr
received a
$3,160 th000 capital appropriation in
order to replace our existing Tims
system which stood for tax information
management
system uh Tims was implemented in 1990
it was obsolete it was a um Cobalt
system so if you think black black
background green flashing cursor I
remember my first day at Dr I put my
hand on The Mouse and the person that
was training me was like Oh no you're
not going to need that um lots of
function keys lots of tabbing between
Fields um so Tims was great but it had
so maybe a decade before yes um so it
had reached its life not only in terms
of function ity but also there were
security concerns coming into the the
age that we're in um so we really needed
a new upgraded system and so that's rims
so rims is used not only by us at Dr but
also by tax practitioners and
taxpayers we have um an outward facing
portal called Granite tax connect which
I'll show you in a minute um it really
revolutionized everything that we did um
so it was implemented by Dr in
partnership with our DOI it counterparts
fast Enterprises was the vendor that was
selected and we implemented their
commercial off-the-shelf software called
gen tax um the vast majority of states
in the US use gen tax so it is a very um
powerful Tax Administration software um
fast primarily um implements Tax
Administration software so they're
really the experts in the area it has
served us very well Implement
implementation consisted of three phases
which took about a year each um and the
total contract for that um was just over
29 million what you will see on page 56
is the rollouts we were on time and on
budget for the implementation of rims
even during the middle of a global
pandemic so we're very proud of that and
I brag about it every chance that I get
on page 57 this is a snapshot of the
current Granite tax
connect um a few things that I want to
call your attention to this is obviously
where you would go to file and pay your
taxes as a taxpayer or as a tax
practitioner but there are things you
can do on here that you don't need to
have an account for um the first is
under taxpayer reference which is the
second box down on the left um you can
request a form to be mailed to you not a
2025 indd estimate because we won't send
it but you could request other forms to
be mailed to you um if you had received
a tax notice from us under businesses
and individuals you could submit an
appeal request right through GTC that
has been um very helpful for both us and
taxpayers and then lastly on the bottom
right Under reporting the first um
bullet there says look up a meals and
rentals tax license so if you're ever
wondering if that restaurant in that in
your town has an M&R license you can
look it up right there and if they don't
out you can do that
anonymously um representative elme has a
question Follow by
representative are you sure about 1990
because in 1990 the whole state had
practically no
computerization I believe that's when
the development of Tims came in that we
began developing it um around 1990 it
was a homegrown system it was developed
here um and like I said served us well
but did not contain all of our tax types
um and so we had a number of disparate
systems and so rims modernized and
brought everything together that
consisted of three desktop computers
that were already
old on that were being pumped in by
everybody in the Dr taking
terms 1990 was the date that I was given
um I was eight at the time so I'd have
to go by what I was well I was
new radio sha
trs8 I've got a we have two more
questions uh I want to be mindful of the
time it's 12:30 representative om yeah
thank you for an excellent presentation
uh I ask a favor of you the C the clerk
would like to keep this as a personal
copy would you have an extra one for the
it okay representative
Brier I just wanted to comment in 1990 I
actually uh did an audit over at Revenue
Administration and uh they had just put
it in put it in okay okay good confirmed
yes representative shamberg thank you Mr
chairman I've been waiting 45 minutes to
ask this question since since
representative Aly brought it
up all right on page 14 and page 19
okay back when representative major was
chair and represent Al's ranking
member they tried to get a study done to
collect data now this is the question it
wasn't it wasn't approved because
everybody wanted to rush into this on
page 14 those one at the bottom of the
triangle there
1,152 companies that paid an estimated
62 1 million in business profits
tax if they had sold every product out
the door out of the
state what would have been their
business profits tax that they would
have owed the state if all their sales
went out after they've done their cost
analysis
and probably very little very little so
that means we could have lost or could
lose theoretically 620 $1
million in
Revenue well
because that's just a the theoretical
question I just want to hear you say you
could lose you could okay thank
you um and it's good gain and you could
gain it all right it's all looking to
the customer um okay I just very quickly
there is two more slides that are very
quick that actually um is less of me
bragging about rims although there's a
little bit of bragging but it actually
does matter a little bit for Revenue
estimating purposes so on page 52 this
is a lot of words but this basically is
saying
that part of The Debt
Service um for the bonds that were
issued in order for Dr to pay almost $30
million for a new system part of those
bonds the principal and interest needs
to be paid by Revenue uplift so the
Assumption was that rims would generate
Revenue we would have more Revenue under
a modern system and so the way that that
happens is every year every fiscal year
up to $4 million of general fund revenue
is transferred out into a dedicated fund
to pay that Rim's Debt Service and so
what you'll see see on page 59 is the
history of those transfers
so in fiscal year 20 our we were not
fully up and running so we didn't
transfer anything in 21 we were
partially underway so we transferred 2.2
million and then 22 23 and 24 we've
reached the 4 million in every year so
that means we have transferred 14.2
million we have 25.8 million to go
assuming that we will do 4 million a
year every year we will be making
transfers for seven more years how did
we identify additional Revenue as a
result of rims right now it's really
three ways
One turns out if you just remind people
that they have a tax notice they'll pay
it so we had no ability under Tims we
would just send out a tax notice and if
it wasn't paid their appeal rights ended
and we sent them to collection now under
rims we have the ability after 30 days
to send a reminder letter and you know
what a lot of people pay when you just
remind them that they have an amount
owed so last year um we generated
revenue from reminder to pay from the
use of federal tax information that's
information from the IRS they have very
strict rules and regulations on how that
information can be stored and used and
our old system did not meet those
regulations so we can now use federal
tax information um in a much better way
and then lastly we now have the ability
to go online and you can request a
payment plan and so long as it falls
within certain parameters it is
automatically granted with no
intervention from the Department that
has significantly increased compliance
um and so all told last year those three
things generated 14 and5
million um but per statute we only
transferred the 4 million to the
dedicated fund so the point here is rims
successful so you would sign into the
portal and request a payment plan um
right through granite tax
connect oh to be notified you oh we send
we send you a reminder letter both in
the mail and in the portal
yeah
yeah sounds good okay so long as you
don't have a dog it's okay that e that
eats it all right are we all set anyone
have any questions one last question
thank you Mr chair so one uh final
question would be so if anybody's really
heartbroken over the indd tax going away
did they have the option to write a
check to the state or will the state I
am not going to cash
that okay because I don't want to have
to pay it back thank you okay thank you
commissioner step this is very valuable
looks like uh y yeah Chris may have a
comment or two just a quick reminder for
the committee so the document I gave you
earlier that has the coin on the front
if you flip the page it had the list of
the um people from our
office on the top of the page is a web
our website just want to draw your
attention to the one that starts
specific to budget and Reven Revenue
documents all the documents that you
were um handed out last week at the
economic presentations all the documents
that you received today and going
forward will be posted on that website
so if you're leave here in a rush and
you leave all your documents here and
you wanted to review something you could
go to our website and take a look at
that um so I just wanted to make sure
that that you were aware of that also
that the meetings are being streamed so
that if you wanted to go back and listen
to Lindy's presentation you could do
that uh I think you can fast forward
through me pretty quickly and get to her
so but if you just for members too as
they I think it was mentioned early on
um that members may come and go due to
other other obligations with during the
day for presentations on bills that
you're sponsoring or other meetings you
might have you might not be here for
some of the presentations so that the
information will be
available that's all I wanted to just
come up and say thank you Chris um any
questions for Chris yes represent sod
just a comment uh when you watch this
the presentations on YouTube you could
watch it at a faster speed it's you get
through it quicker that way yeah you can
speed up the voice right yeah good thank
you okay thank you very much um and uh
we will now conclude this U info session
um and uh we will be back here at 130
for um hearing a couple of bills
um public hearings on actually it'll be
this the kick off to our public hearing
schedule um we'll hear at 1:30 HB 83
increasing the minimum age for sports
betting and at 2:00 HP 163 relative to
state fund so we'll see you all back
you
e
okay the time being
136 I'm going to open the public hearing
83 and uh we will ask representative
bill your M your microphone thank you
for the honor of um letting me present
your first bill of the
term so I'm representative Sally fellows
and I represent Plymouth Ashlin and
holderness and what I'd like to talk to
you today about is raising the age for
uh sports betting from 18 to
21 as a little bit of the background in
2018 the US Supreme Court struck down a
federal law that had prohibited sports
betting in almost all of the states as
of September last year 40 States now
allow sports betting and 32 of those
betting the minimum age for sports
betting is 21 in all but seven states
two of those states do not allow online
betting this bill raises the minimum age
for only sports betting from 18 to 21
the minimum age for charity gaming
remains at
18 the fiscal note shows that um 18 19
and 20 year olds wagered more than $14
million in FY
24 so let me explain why I'm asking you
to raise the
age we all know that 18 19 and 20 year
olds particularly males are for far more
likely than mature adults to engage in
Risky and dangerous behaviors such as
smoking reckless driving binge drinking
and
gambling
because their cognitive ability is eval
to evaluate the consequences of their
actions has not completely
developed we also know about the
addictive addictive qualities of cell
phone
apps the damage they can have on mental
health of teens and young adults and how
those apps suck up time that could be
spent in healthy
activities and
finally we know most sports betting
takes place on cell phones where bets
can be made on events
happening around the world this easy 247
access paired with the fastpaced betting
opportunities has an addiction rate
higher than any other form of
gambling raising the age the minimum age
for sports betting to 21 will give high
school students and recent grads three
more years to mature then they will be
better able to budget their bets avoid
financial disaster and avoid emotional
distress the purpose of this bill is to
reduce the number of gamblers who will
become
addicted when I when you have a chance I
would ask you to please read the um
Associated Press article that I um
distributed with my
thank you representative um does anyone
questions uh yes representative shanberg
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative what
is the the difference between an
18-year-old in charitable gaming betting
and sports
betting is
the well so right now 18-year-olds can
um bet do sports betting in the
casinos um
and well they can right now they can do
sports betting either in the casinos or
online and I gave I read an abbreviated
version of my testimony and the actual
what I passed out it told you that there
were four casinos where they can do
sports betting the difference in terms
of um potential
addiction is that the casinos at least
now they're not open 24 hours a day so
it's it takes up more of somebody's time
and they they can't be in the casino 24
hours a day but they can be with their
bets yes represent
opal thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question representative
fellows I I I'm a little confused in
reading your um repaired
statement uh you say the fiscal note
shows at 18 19 and 20 year olds wagered
more than 14 million in fy2 24 but it
um I you can go online if you just
Google new Hampshire lottery sports
betting Revenue you will get a report
that looks like this so this report
shows the total amount it has um two it
has the one section is about mobile
sports betting one is about uh in the
casinos and then the third section is
the total and so all I did is the fiscal
note tells us that the 18 19 and 20 year
olds um
wagered
1.5% of of the total Wagers so I just
applied that
1.9% to the total amount that was
wagered well followup actually I didn't
get to ask my question but um as I'm
reading the fiscal note um it you're
you're correct it says state revenue
from um sports betting was $ 33.6
million total and that um individuals
under the age of 21 accounted for
1.9% of that which they're saying the
revenue uh that you could attribute to
$639,000 total so that's Revenue to the
state so you start out with this if you
had a copy of this report the First
Column says handle and that's the amount
of money that was B Deb and the second
column says how much is retained by the
operator and then the third column is
the one that that figure is in that's
the amount that comes into the state as
state revenue right does that answer
your question one one more followup I gu
I guess what I'm getting at
representative is what this committee is
most concerned about is revenue and the
impact on Revenue um that's our charge
um and it and it seems to me that that
people might get confused about the 14
million when in fact what we're talking
about appears to be an impact of um less
than $640,000
to revenue to the state if if if your
bill were to be adopted that it's so so
what I'm telling you in my statement in
my testimony is I'm telling you how much
money the 18 19 and 20 year-olds bet how
much they placed for wages in the end
the amount of that that that filters
back and becomes state revenue is the
600,000 figure so that's the impact on
the state budget the impact on the
families of those teens is that they bet
14 more than $14
million and
that you know I mean they won some of
time representative sod yeah thank you
do you have any results about how they
do comparatively to other ages as far as
winning and losing so I having a little
hard time hearing you so the results of
uh winning and losing versus other ages
do you have any results like that do
they do better or worse than um you mean
older people you mean um if you were
looking for the type of gambling that
gives you the best likely return yeah
their win ratio do they so I
can I can tell you for the lottery
tickets that the mega Buck is the one
with the best odds uh sports betting is
definitely not not the best and it um it
could be the worst one of the things I'm
not I don't do any sports betting but
there are different kinds of Wagers you
can make when you you do Sports spts
betting and there's one I don't know if
you have any experts here something that
begins with P that is the the least
likely um has the worst
odds that's the best way that's the
it yes represent ORS thank you Mr chair
so I think the question being asked was
the age group
embedding I think rep sod was asking you
if teenagers do they win more or less
than other age groups like 21 to 25
maybe or is that the question oh o oh
okay
so this is just an anecdote so somebody
who I had a conversation with a A friend
of mine who um knows a lot about sports
betting and he tells me that the
teenagers they're they they're just they
don't do well at all because they think
they know they think they they they're
teenagers they they think they're really
smart smarter than their parents and
they think they're very smart and can
figure out which team is going to win
and they they don't even know they don't
know what they don't know and they
probably lose more than some other
people I would think firsttime betters
probably takes a while to get used to it
too
follow uh yes follow up on that so um am
I would I be right to assume then uh if
the question of lowering the voting age
came up to 16 you would be against that
as
well lowering the voting
age I would have to give that a lot of
thought I don't know I don't know if I
would support it or
not I don't want to increase a voting
sure any other
questions okay seeing none thank you
thank you and and um the next person may
be able to answer some of your questions
better than I
Warner good afternoon Miss Warner before
you begin yes the way these mics work is
you push it to talk and then if you want
to listen carefully
got it thank you appreciate it uh good
afternoon everyone uh chairman and
legislative members my name is Marley
Warner and I am the CEO of the
Massachusetts Council on gaming and
health we are not for-profit public
health agency that offers programs and
services from primary prevention through
long-term recovery related to gambling
in Massachusetts we also offer services
in Vermont and Michigan and Arizona and
previously have offered services in
Connecticut at Wisconsin and Colorado we
are neither for nor against legalized
gambling in my line of work I'm often
heard speaking about operating in the
gray space typically people consider
most issues black or white but I would
say that most aspects of gambling are
actually pretty gray the products the
type the speeds these are all things
that are considered in the gray space
because while they are legal and mostly
regulated not everyone agrees on what is
quote right or wrong there are often
moral concerns connected to gambling and
research can find positive and negative
consequences for example there has been
research that signifies that promotions
for and visits to traditional casinos
can be beneficial for older adults their
physical and emotional health due to the
social connections walking around the
casino even elevated heart rates from
winning or or almost winning in a casino
and what that can provide
on the other hand other research notes
all the ways that the financial losses
and disagreements among family members
can have severe negative consequences on
their mental health and their
connections to ties at home older adults
gambling is very much what I consider a
gray issue but what I'm here to talk to
about talk with you all about today to
me is a clear black and white issue no
research no research in the world has
been done on youth younger adults that
would tell you that a less mature brain
is more appropriate for gambling than a
more mature brain it is 100% a fact that
an immature prefrontal cortex is not
able to discern the level of risk-taking
that is involved in gambling in
particular with sports wagering well I
don't pretend to be a neuroscientist so
please don't ask me any Neuroscience
questions I do know that we can't argue
with the black and white issue that
18-year-olds are not prepared to be able
to appropriately react and respond to
the lur of advertisements and promotions
available on Sports spending apps youth
gambling is one of a few black and white
issues in the gambling
field in fact in all the states where we
work and you just heard representative
fellows um talk about all the states um
where Sports gambling is legal the age
to gamble on Sports wagering is
21 that is true in the vast majority of
the states where Sports wagering has
been legalized it is most certainly the
more common public policy nationally
with all state regulated and tribal
gaming the gambling offerings in those
states do financially very well if not
better with only 21y olds betting on
them in those States there's truly no
reason to put your young people here in
New Hampshire at risk in fact there's no
reason to put any young people at risk
I've personally spent the last 24 years
of my career care working on this issue
my organization has worked with
legislators and Regulators to strengthen
the safety net available to people who
make the choice to gamble in
Massachusetts there are significant
regulations tools and resources that
have been put forth to ensure that young
people are not put In Harm's Way and
appropriately so as one of the largest
risk factors for someone ending up with
a gambling problem is the early age of
onset of gambling the earlier they start
the more more likely they are to develop
a gambling problem and so it's quite
upsetting to me that after all of our
efforts almost all young Massachusetts
residents need to do is to cross the
border into New Hampshire to gamble
whether to set up the app or walk into a
casino it has been a write of passage
for 18-year-olds typically young men on
or near their 18th birthday to visit New
Hampshire for this very purpose this is
particularly distressing as we talk to
gambling treatment providers ERS high
school counselors College administrators
Etc who are seeking who are seeing
excuse me the negative impacts of kids
gambling we know that young people don't
have the mental emotional or financial
capacity to bounce back from dramatic
Sports wagering losses in fact I used to
say that there was no form of gambling
that was more harmful than another but
we now have forms of gambling and
research that refutes that Sports
wagering and online casino gambling are
absolutely seen to be more problematic
than other forms of of gambling
regardless of age in New Hampshire you
have both and you're currently allowing
18-year-olds to gamble on them and is
with that that I need to also share that
I am a mom in addition to a CEO I'm a
Massachusetts mother to three kids
including two teenage boys and a
10-year-old daughter my boys are huge
sports fanatics they are already in in
data on television during live events on
social media apps but they are
absolutely feeling the pre peer pressure
of going going to New Hampshire to
gamble in fact I L an educational
here um at my younger son school where I
spoke to 300 young men who sat there and
told me like they were reading me
something they knew was 100% true that
the least harmful form of gambling was
Sports waging because there they could
make the most educated gambling
decisions and that they had more control
over the way the wager would go these
are babes making uninformed decisions
I'm here today to ask for your help both
as a CEO and a mom please support House
Bill 83 and increase New Hampshire's age
to gamble on Sports W wagering from 18
to 21 thank
questions seeing none thank you thank
uh next I have next I have an forgive me
on the first name I can't read it
completely J J
jamine
rero hello I'm Janine rero Chief
marketing officer for the Massachusetts
Council on gaming and health I'm also a
former marketing director for a casino
here in New Hampshire uh with a retail
draftking sports book and I live in
Auburn New Hampshire I also support
raising the gambling age from 18 to 21
um from an operator perspective I'll
just give my anecdote is that this
particular segment between 18 to 21 year
olds they are not a segment that
operators are marketing to very well
anyway um at least on the retail side
because with sports books you have
sports bars and of course you can't
necessarily promote with them a beer or
a food package and their wallet size is
not significant enough um I know we were
just discussing the the bigger um the
bigger amount of Revenue but even on an
individual level they're not significant
enough to the operator um but again that
small benefit the bigger risk is of
course as Marlene explained that the
younger somebody gets used to that
normalization of gambling that's too
accessible it really does become a
problem so I support raising the age to
you and last but not least I have H
Katie
lalia hi good morning my name is Katie
leulier I'm a marketing coordinator with
the mass Council of gaming and health I
am a lifelong resident of New
Hampshire and I support the bill to
increase New Hampshire's age to gamble
21 uh any questions for
Katie saying none thank you for your
testimony that's all I have for pin
cards is there anyone else who would
card okay
seeing none I will close the public
what oh should
we should we have him
come I'm going to reopen the hearing on
HB
yeah and we'll hear from the director of
directory of director of Lottery uh good
afternoon Mr chairman members of the
committee uh my name is Charlie McIntyre
I have the privilege of being the
director of the New Hampshire Lottery
and have been for almost 15 years uh and
so the question regarding age 18 to 21
is really a policy decision of you folks
and the governor and so we wouldn't take
a position on this bill our fiscal note
represents what we believe to be be the
fiscal impact of the state um and that
$600,000 figure is essentially what
would would have been last year's net
revenue to the state from
better as are 18 19 and 20 so but I'm
happy to answer any questions you might
have or anything else rent
elme thank you do you have any thoughts
about how difficult it would be to
ascertain the age of 18 to 21 year
olds online it's it's easy the
technology exists through the through
the phone it's actually quite um
Advanced uh in person is another
question so certainly it's open to it's
one of the most difficult things we have
is you you can buy lottery ticket 18
there's 1,400 stores that sell lottery
tickets essentially and there are
between five and 50 clerks at any given
store who have to be trained on age
verification so that's one of the most
difficult things we have uh it's where
human beings are the technology on the
the app is actually quite
good anybody
when you gamble you either have to have
a debit card or cash is that correct
correct there's no current law that
prohibits credit uh we just as a matter
of policy don't do it because candidly I
personally and our agency in general
just don't like the thought of using
debt so it's either debit card or it's
cash or like an a transfer something
like
that followup followup
therefore would it be correct to say
that a person who's placed in a bet is
limited by the amount of hard currency
they have on
correct yes representative
Murphy is it possible to make this
Revenue neutral by increasing how much
the state gets from the the
operator I mean anything's possible but
we currently are the number two or three
jurisdiction out of the 40 in terms of
profitability to the state uh we have a
negotiated contract that is the Envy of
Most states around the US and so and
also as part of that agreement
DraftKings actually built an office in
nashwa and employees people in that
office and so uh it's a very
exceptionally lucrative contract so not
anything's possible but I would imagine
okay yes
representative yeah thank you director
McIntyre um my observation is that the
uh
control of
the uh sports betting is very tightly
restricted to the boundaries of New
Hampshire my cell phone doesn't work if
I'm just on the border have to be in New
Hampshire so isn't it true that anyone
from Massachusetts truly has to move
into New Hampshire not just be nearby to
use the DraftKings application they
would have so there's a the state is Geo
fenced which is easy on the west side
because of the conut river it's a little
tough on the southern border so it's
around 300 feet in is where the border
is and so um I will tell you the early
days of sports betting the most popular
places were the Portsmouth liquor store
and the Mall of New Hampshire and then
liquor store in New hampsh in Nash um a
lot of folks came up from Massachusetts
tobet and so if you had the DraftKings
app and you loaded it it would work here
if you were within further distance you
couldn't do it for Massachusetts you
barred okay anybody
else chairman should I fill out a red
card just uh pink card yeah that'd be
good P card pin card yeah thank
you we don't have any red cards
here that's
soccer yes that would be great thank you
premier league is available for betting
I'm a lifelong Liverpool fan so good
good to know thank you
director anybody else like to
testify okay seeing none I will now
y
okay we will now open the public hearing
on HB
163 the time being 205 and uh recognize
representative
elme
you can you can start looks like I just
have me oh these are readers
uh on I
um introduced this bill from the
dedicated funds
committee um we discussed it a bit there
and then the treasurer and the com
controller and I went off and did a lot
of detail work um the purpose of it is
is to straighten out a lot of things in
612 the list of dedicated funds uh which
we hadn't realized were
problems um or that were totally
Antiquated
and we
did I'm going to now H try to
read uh my my printer does not connect
with my
computer on a quarter of a century ago
the LBA AO and I aided by legislative
drafting restructured the 612 list which
was fairly small and half of it was uh
repealed
already um we
found and deleted long inactive funds
added the trusts and endowment funds
told the agencies which funds were their
responsibilities a lot of the agencies
didn't even know these dedicated funds
existed that were in their Province and
sent out a message that any dedicated
funds not within 612 would have their
funds sent to the general
fund uh that one was repealed a few
years later but it served its purpose at
first um and we assigned all the funds
to legislative committees
since then we haven't changed the basic
structure but we and I and the finance
committee have been trying out a lot of
different methods of getting the other
um committees to pay attention to the
fact that they had these dedicated
funds because and we are still getting
committees that send bills out that are
already in in a dedicated fund that they
don't need to send out again they need
to figure out how to make it work so um
that's what the
original uh plan
was
but we we do have a near-perfect listing
of the dedicated
funds um of the state now
and oh I'm going I'm going between
sections
um we yeah we do have a near perfect
listing of the dedicated funds of the
state and every year the dedicated fund
committee reviews all the funds of about
a a fifth of all the Departments
rotation cleaning out Deadwood pointing
out overlaps and deviations from the
purpose of the fund checking for
unwarranted increases or losses in fund
balance and recommending fee decreases
or increases to the relevant
committee and sometimes writing the bill
with them but over time a lot of errors
in designation of
fund as uh set up by the state for a
specific
source is that that kind of fund is
confused with a trust that was sent up
by an external group with a specific
purpose and held by the state treasurer
and custodial accounts uh set up by the
courts for specific individuals or
reasons who held and dispers and held
and dispersed by the treasury we had not
really understood the
differences and sometimes we're
classifying one entity as another
entity this revision of 612s resolves
those problems by defin clearly defining
the three types of fund and their
purposes organizing the
funds on uh list and adding several
funds uh that were in departments that
had avoided the the listing before that
was the treasurers doing um and and then
finally we have a list at the end of
this that repeals 13 funds I believe all
of those 13 funds are put in their
proper places in in the legislation
um in the text between the two of
them we may have killed one of the funds
I'm not sure but if we did it no longer
exist it it does not exist in practice
we have a fair number of funds at this
uh
have uh zero balance have had zero
balance for quite a while have had zero
balance ever since they were F started
which the agencies in in
question insists they want to keep
around because maybe some money would
come from the feds for a purpose then
they'll need it right away or
maybe uh there will be an emergency and
we need to pour money into that fund so
that we can use it
properly and uh We've in general given
given them permission to do that and
we've also removed uh long time ago now
we've removed the uh fund for the
nuclear
plant which uh is very well audited
already and a number and recently we've
removed the universities because they
are audited separately and a few others
that are in that General box
but um we
about uh a
month uh emailing back and forth to each
other finding the things that the other
person hadn't found and I think it's in
pretty good shape
so I take any questions thank you
represent El me and as you can see if
you look at the sponsor list um I'm I'm
on here as well as well as if you read
through the list all those people were
on the the committee joint committee to
study this so um we we went through with
the fine tooth com uh representa Aly did
the probably the Lion Share of coming
through it uh but we've also had Dr look
at it as well yes
representative thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you representative for taking my
question I think this may be a really
you've obviously a lot of work here I'm
also uh Trustee of trust funds in
Greenland we deal with trust funds I see
trusts written up here some of these are
trust
funds uh it's probably a different whole
structure than we would do in a in a
town thing but by
merely
restating a state law or putting that
overlay on
this you can take a trust fund and move
it into something else without a probate
or non-judicial settlement or things
like that that's that's all I that's
about my extent of my knowledge I'm just
asking the question yeah well trust
funds in general have to go to the
attorney and escros I think also have to
go to the attor Attorney General's
office of charitable trusts and spend a
fair amount of time
being checked over and then they finally
decide yes you can move it or no you
can't we had a case with
two very small um trust funds set up by
well-meaning people in uh Kean area one
of which is for Keen State University no
Keen State
College uh to two of them both of them
are for the Keen State College one of
them is also for Plymouth um to divvy up
scholar ship
funds the money hasn't been used because
there isn't enough
money to do that um and we wanted I
wanted to just remove them completely
and stick them into the university
system and say go at it um or just yes
just use it for Keane and
Plymouth as part of the money that you
give them uh it didn't
um uh it didn't pass the test of the
AG's office and so what they've decided
to do is to just send a check every year
for the amount of money to the
appropriate college and tell them to
spend it for
that
so um
but on the trust funds in the Treasury
Office
are are different and I think probably
better audited than the ones in the
towns my Treasurer probably would object
to my saying that representative
om yeah thank you representative Al for
your service on the study committee is
it fair to say that there are no policy
changes in this bill strictly a
streamline of the process there there
are no changes in of policy in this bill
um because you reminded me um
there was a suggestion that we take the
dedicated fund committee out of the
process for everything except the trust
the uh the original dedicated funds that
are not trusts and not
escr and some of us maybe all of us I
can't remember F back about that because
it meant that um we do have a fair
number of funds
that are
dangerously near zero that are supposed
to be taking care of things we have
others that are up to four times as much
as they need and aren't saving for
anything in
particular and it helps if we can look
at them once every five years and
um give them a some ideas about how they
situation yes representative shamber
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative taking this question on
page two lines 28
through
33 there's a change for the
administrator of each fund to go from
September to October 15th to
report but there was no change for the
November 15th uh is that just a simple
process of of
the account managers needed more fund or
the administrators need more more time
before October 15th uh are there
deadlines in there somewhere that they
have to meet this is something that came
up uh a change that came from the com
troller and I think that uh we didn't
ask about it at the time why they wanted
to to make that a month later the
November
one
is is I think kind of important to stay
with and they felt that they could get
those once they had those
reports
digitally uh by October 15th they could
get them easily over to to the format
I don't think we asked that question but
no they were the ones that volunteered
it I'm thinking many of these reports uh
need to come out by November 1st and so
this probably is giving a little more
time maybe to get it finalized but it's
but it's being done at least two weeks
before the November 1st yeah that there
is
a a standard format for all of these in
what I used to call a telephone book but
most people don't get it anymore it's
online
uh
and the difficulty is that it is the
only place that we've got that gives
what the fund operator thinks is the
purpose of the
fund uh they're required to give the
purpose of the fund as well as on what
the last five years of of um ending and
beginning balances was
and on there was three two three years
no it's been five years now because we
just had them in again the new
department when it was new of cultural
resour and natural resources had Absolut
they they threw everything they could
think of into that that they didn't want
anywhere else and it was pretty
difficult for them we talked to them the
first time I think after only a year
they had managed to mix up all the
purposes they had no idea what was going
on and we worked with them and and their
is there anyone else who would like to
this seeing seeing none then um I will
public no I don't we have a oh no no yes
we do need it yeah what's that no we do
I'm sorry we do need it I thought we had
it
okay with that I'm going to close the
163 yes Jordan
Hy um Mr chair it appears as
than it appears as though uh most in the
commit are
understand that this is a housekeeping
Bill HB 163 is it appropriate to move to
Executive session at this
point um it is
possible um I'll talk to the uh ranking
member
shortly um while she after she fills out
um so let's uh we'll just uh hold off
okay it seems like um representative Aly
is uh good with it I'm I'm good with it
so I think we're going to go into we're
going to go into EXA
163 and I will give the clerk a couple
minutes to catch up with us because he
wasn't necessarily expecting his
[Music]
um yeah I think we we push it off till
week
and we don't have Subs so you're just
GNA go through all the Republicans first
okay but you go you come to me last you
already know that okay um do I have a
motion we need I need a motion to um on
sure okay I move House Bill 163
relative to State funds okay Susan Aly
represent as opposed to
it representative ol seconds it uh any
further discussion on this before we I
vote represent Aly are you all set yes
you're light is on so oh okay all right
um when the clerk is ready I'll ask him
to take the role on this the motion
163 thank you Mr chairman again the vot
is on House Bill 163 relative to State
funds moved by representative Aly
seconded by representative alry
representative
alry I representative not
present clerk votes
yes representative sui yes
representative
AES not
present representative Smith is not
present representative
Tierney
yes representative Scott
buer
yes representative
Ford yes
representative
Murphy yes representative
Aly yes representative Southworth is not
present representative Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative Jeffrey
Smith not here representative
Opel I representative spar yes and
chairman J
jigan janigan we we'll work we'll work
on that later uh
yes uh we have unanimous vote with one
two three four five members
absent total so it's 15 zero how many
20 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 clerk counts 15
members in favor
none
oppose and five
absent motion
carries sounds good
um representative Aly can this go on
consent okay we'll put this on the
consent
calendar and um without objection unless
somebody has an objection of course we
all just voted for
it yeah but some people okay
yeah let me close I'll close the
executive session or no maybe I won't
close it yet um without so the consent
calendar for those of you who are new um
there's a bunch of bills if they're like
you know in this case 15 to zero or 17
to1 or whatever they can go on something
called the consent calendar unless they
have a FIS I believe unless they have a
fiscal uh impact um then they'd have to
come up or vote when we go into house
session
at the next session um there'll be
something where we vote on the consent
calendar and the the speaker will say
all in favor of adopting the consent
calendar any bills like this one on
consent will automatically be passed uh
or well I should say would
automatically whatever their designation
is this is OTP so it's going to be
passed there's other bills that most of
the people in the committee say itl
which means inexpedient to legislate
those will be killed um and then it
takes I believe it takes 10 people or
did the rules change on that to take it
off they tried to change it to three but
I don't think it I don't think it passed
didn't okay it's still 10 so it takes 10
people if there's 10 reps who don't want
it to go consent they've got to get
together and let the clerk know yes the
party that use your phone as the party
that wanted to get to
three uh was saying uh there was a
coalition of people formed on the
Republican side that promised to all
vote 10 people vote uh
uh SP co-sponsor the resolution the the
requests for can to come off consent uh
so that a whole lot of things came off
consent that those 10 people weren't
voting
for I'm not sure I understood what you
just said I'm sorry I'm a little goofy
at the moment okay that made sense
inside baseball politics for those that
are watching at home yeah okay but the
10 people doesn't seem to make a
difference yeah so okay so it's unlikely
that 10 people are going to get together
and pull this this one off consent um
okay I will close the executive session
on HB
163 and um that concludes our business
for today however I just want to talk
about next week um
um next
week next week I will be
scheduling Monday the 27th and Tuesday
the 28th starting at 10 a.m. and um the
27th is going to
be
um what is it it's we're not going to be
doing any public hearings in the see
we're going to have some some more
agency presentations I mean all this is
in lie of us uh getting to the point
where we when we do Revenue estimates we
have some basis for what we're talking
about so um the yeah so the the calendar
I have right now is
um January 27th which is Monday we'll
hear from Department of admin Services
Treasury Department Department of State
Bureau this will be in the calendar by
the way Department of State Bureau of
Securities regulation and judicial
branch that'll be 10 to 12 and then from
1 to three we'll hear from the insurance
department the Lottery Commission and
fish and game um I don't think we will I
don't think we'll be executing any bills
on that day um the next day because the
only well the only other Bill we have is
HB 83 but
um and then uh a couple of us going to
get together to firm up the bills that
we will hear public hearings or work
sessions or uh whatever for Tuesday but
the thing the important thing is Monday
10 to 3
Tuesday 10
to 3 3:30 something like
that any
questions okay
Susan you're all set okay all right
thank you
everyone that'll be in the calendar